e
[Musique]
vous êtes prêt à diriger sur des jeux au
temps que c'est pas sur les couilles ça
passe à les entendre les enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ami de l'homme en noir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en bas l'émission qui parle avec
nous ce soir
francine d'estelle
[Applaudissements]
un monde
dany boon
pensez meilleur dj tôt
fédérer
paulino
mano solo
leurs ges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ecri ballon tout le monde parle de
blind test de bien
[Musique]
bonsoir lensois pied
[Applaudissements]
wells contre nature
[Musique]
bon bah voilà petit break
on prend deux heures on va faire le
point et on revient au comment ça va
mais réalise
j'ai déjà dit ça va non non de seconde
on abat c'est toi c'est vrai de la
lumière
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai bien mais en anglais et moi la
grille bonsoir bien girouard que j'ai ma
carte c'est vraiment alors nagui j'ai
envie de dire comme neuf
comment ça va ça va bien écoute on air
on va comme en histoire j'ai vue de la
course au large et non non non j'ai vu
du beau monde
ah oui il ya valeria golino pourquoi
notre chute dont il faut que j'y aille
mais tu as tu été sur le plateau la
voilà c'est ça qu'est ce tu fais de la
télé pour une fois donc j'en profite et
peut-être de trois questions
est-ce que sucer c'est tromper alors je
fais pas de politique
c'est politique est plutôt sado-maso
plutôt salée ou plutôt maso nagui je me
suis pas trouvé de plateau c'est bien
c'est bien celui-là la 'biotech' vite ça
va mieux on s'échauffe un peu très bien
attends tu peux laisser sa place à
patrick sabatier que des essais suivants
pour le casting
[Musique]
jack hayes francine vistelle
bonsoir anciennement soir laurent baffie
francine distel des pommes des poires l
escaut bilbilu partout voilà bien alors
le jeudi 22 juillet dernier au petit
matin sacha distel s'éteignait francine
dans votre propriété familiale du ray
young canada elles et ils laissés
inachevés un livre sur sa vie qu'il
avait commencé un an et demi plus tôt en
compagnie de l'écrivain bruno tessarech
et derrière le dernier chapitre est
resté sous forme de synopsis alors c'est
un livre important pour sacha distel
parce que pour lui ça a constitué un des
éléments de son changement d'image et
oui c'est ce qu'il voulait laisser en
tous les cas sans savoir qu'il
laisserait aussi vite
ouais c'est un peu comme son dernier cd
dont il était venu parler ici d'ailleurs
qui s'appelait envers et contre vous
tiens il voulait absolument montrer
qu'il n'était pas seulement le le
créateur de chansons rigolotes mais
aussi un grand musicien et un grand
crooner un grand musicien qui a écrit de
très belles chansons qui faisait souvent
la face b
ouais mais comme c'était la face à qui
avaient du succès forcément elles n'ont
pas été voir longtemps connu que les
autres sur livre qui lui tenait à coeur
énormément à coeur et c'est pour ça que
vous êtes là ce soir pour en parler à sa
place oui hélas et c'est moi qui suis en
première ligne et
je le fais et je fais par amour pour
sacha parce que ce livre est important
pour lui il fallait que je vienne le
présenter donc vous allez nous le lien
voilà lançant pour mot si c'est
difficile pour vous de venir parler de
ce livre à la télévision on vous a
jamais vu en fait vous non c'est au
contraire ça me fait plaisir bien non
mais heureux que vous soyez là en tous
les cas merci voilà alors toute façon
vous vous croyez à la vie après la mort
donc vous pensez que ce chat ma vie
après la vie
oui c'est plus gai oui bon c'est que
sacha distel va vous aider ce soir
complètement ouais alors dans ce bouquin
sacha raconte sa vie ses parents son
père émigré russe propriétaire d'un
magasin de luminaires à clignancourt bon
danseur son père un séducteur né un peu
comme un peu comme sacha et puis sa mère
famille juive bourgeoise et son oncle le
fameux raymond ventura ray ventura le
créateur de l'orchestré des collégiens
qui sera à l'origine de la passion de
sacha pour la musique c'est lui qui lui
a vraiment donné le virus
absolument et en tout petit laid il
était passionné rey l'a emmené à des des
concerts et sasha unef coup de foudre
alors sacha raconte la guerre sa mère
arrêtée par la gestapo
les retrouvailles et en 1947 ray ventura
lui demande d'être le réveil matin d'un
artiste qui s'appelle henri salvador
pour s'occuper de lui sur le tournage
d'un film et henri salvador lui fait
découvrir frank sinatra et dizzy
gillespie toujours pour le compte de son
oncle sacha part aux usa en 1952 et à
l'âge de 19 ans il découvre stan getz
miles davis charlie parker
enfin c'est une révélation complète pour
lui complète t
oui c'est il a en fait commencé comme
musicien de jazz mois là ensuite il
devient directeur artistique au disque
versailles chez son oncle et ventura et
il devient le meilleur guitariste
français pendant sept ans de suite
oui c'est vrai c'est des trucs que les
gens savent pas tout ça se passait avant
moi oui je suis quand même au courant
poids alors là on entre dans l'éducation
sentimentale de sacha distel ça se
passait avant vous aussi vous êtes un
peu plus au courant pas tellement j'ai
découvert beaucoup de choses dans ce
livre qui veut dire quand même c'est que
sacha était incroyablement beau tu es
magnifique guigou vraiment il était
charmant
le charme c'est encore oui c'est encore
autre chose alors la première c ette
juliette gréco c'est a duré plus de deux
ans et là on découvre tout de suite
quelque chose qui sera récurrent dans
les grandes histoires d'amour de de
sacha distel c'est qu'il était un peu
dominé par l
je pense enfin en lisant lit j'ai
découvert qu'elle était un peu une
initiatrice ouais mais elle le dominer
parce qu elle n'encourageait pas à
chanter par exemple les équipements par
qui chantait faux survente way
peut-être qu'elle voulait pas perdre
l'accompagnateur nom qu'on lui donne
alors jusqu'au jour elle part avec le
producteur hollywoodien darryl zanuck
c'est terrible la scène dans le bouquin
c'est à dire qu elle lui demande de lui
apporter son son passeport à la gare
et quand ils arrivent dans le
compartiment du du wagon lit il trouve
gréco avec dar imzad succès pour
encadrer dire oui le détail amusant il
découvre à monsieur moustachu et
juliette un peu trop près de la
moustache et j'ai très malheureux très
très très malheureux est ce que sacha
est un sentimental grand sentimental on
le voit pas ce que ça recommence encore
avec jeanne moreau
il ya en parlant de jeanne moreau et 17
une tornade amoureuse alors je sais pas
ce que ça signifie matadi a une idée
comme way tornade amoureusement toujours
pareil lui il est un peu complexés par l
c'est un peu le le petit jeune qui qui
accompagne la vedette porte-bagages
voilà un petit peu voilà jusqu'au jour
où elle se casse avec louis malle à d'où
le nom du jeu
voilà ça c'est la deuxième donc c'est
jeanne moreau et la troisième c'est
brigitte bardot alors brigitte elle
voulait faire des enfants avec les
voulait faire sa vie avec lui ah oui oui
était très très nécessaire oui était
très accroché projet demeure très
accroché lui aussi et puis chacun dans
leur métier c'est ça faisait un petit
peu c'est un ouais bah oui il a toujours
cette image avec elle du dugas arriviste
un peu gigolo quand même un ânon bâton
dénoncé cet accord allait tourner
illicite un un papier du canard enchaîné
qui est grave mais ça c'est la parole de
vérité le canard enchaîné on sait bien
dans le canard on dit le petit jeune
homme qui essaie de se faire un nom à la
sueur de ce qu'on ne saurait trop nommé
oui ça lui a fait plaisir jusqu'au jour
elle le quitte
oui finalement il s'est fait plusieurs
fois c'est fait il s'est fait planter à
chaque fois qu aurait lieu dit ouais il
a dit dire que nous on imaginer sacha
distel comme un mec super séducteur et
tout c'est vrai qu'il a eu des filles
formidables mais à chaque fois il est
dominé est planté oui il était peut-être
tombé lui penser à des choses peut-être
plus sérieuse mais ces dames n'ont ouais
c'était lui le sentimental voilà alors
il parle pas de la mecque strasberg et
pousse vadim comment ça se fait non
c'est dommage parce que c'était une des
plus charmantes
elle est venue ici à votre place elle
nous a raconté son aventure avec sacha
en tous les cas ces trois aventures le
guérissent des stars parce qu'il dit
elle même qu'elle ils ont qu'il restait
un peu vrai voilà il préfère quelqu'un
peut-être de moi mais ma musique
voilà un et en 61 il tombe sur vous vous
êtes au courant là oui complètement
complètement alors sur vous n'avez rien
à voir cette fille de banquier et
championne de ski est vrai que ça change
quoi c'était plutôt la championne de ski
que la fille de manquer vrai que à
l'époque ont réussi un coup de foudre
aux équipes it parent c'est vrai coup de
foudre il dit dès le premier soir j'ai
pensé qu'elle serait la mère de mes
enfants et qu'on aura un compte commun
il a rajouté
comment ça s'est passé la première fois
ça a été un coup de foudre
ouais j'étais tête à megève dans un
restaurant de téléphérique côté du tueur
creuse et s'il faut préciser comment ça
s'est passé
il était en train de manger un petit
morceau de descente et sasha est rentré
dans le dans ce restaurant et il
bavardait avec brosses de trois
personnes qui étaient là et tout d'un
coup il s'est tourné vers moi et il a eu
cette phrase d'une banalité incroyable
je crois que nous sommes déjà rencontrés
ce pas terrible ouais c'est pas terrible
c'est et ça marche
après ça marche 43 ans 43 ans et deux
enfants alors votre secret c'est quoi si
vous n'êtes jamais mêlé de sa vie
professionnelle c'est pour ça que ça a
duré aussi longtemps au je pense pas que
ce soit la raison
non non non ça ça a peut-être aidé non
non vous aussi vous avez suivre enfin
l'indépendant vous avez organisé votre
votre vie de votre côté oui c'est à dire
que je vais j'ai une certaine
personnalité dirons-nous je suis une
sportive il ya des tas de choses que
j'avais envie de faire et que j'ai
continué à faire je voulais faire des
trucs en himalaya je suis allé me
balader dans certains pays avec mes
copines
bon ça charal est un petit peu à cause
de mes absences mais finalement il en
était très fier que j'ai cesse cette
autonomie et 7 s'est rien passé dans
l'himalaya quand vous étiez là parce que
moi qui y ai dit non ma première femme
m'a quitté après un trekking dans
l'himalaya allemand un tracking
ça fini c'est pareil mais c'est pas le
[ __ ] délais et vous non non non rien
j'aime bien les népalais mais ils sont
pas terribles sérieusement bon bah vous
le savez il vous trompez temps en temps
vous saviez à l'époque non bien sûr je
le savais oui et vous réagissiez comment
je disais rien laisser passer l'orage
j'ai laissé passer l'orage c'est que
j'ai des parents qui ont divorcé quand
j'avais 17 ans j'étais ravi qui divorce
parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de se
bagarrer et c'était affreux et je
voulais vraiment réussir ma vie de
famille bon je suis tombé sur un homme
absolument charmant très agréable à
vivre
nous avions deux enfants et c'est pas
comme dans les films américains où il ya
une tromperie on casse tout investir non
sans souffrir quand même sur dix
souffrent r oui vous avez bien sûr bien
sûr mais je m'en suis remise finalement
au bout du compte ça quand même été une
réussite
ouais c'est le danger quand épouse un
playboy aussi c'était un playboy
oui c'est ce qu'on m'a dit non playboy
est pas le bon terme
beau gosse charme beau gosse charme r1
que talentueux non c'était pas et que tu
as n'ont pas dit non on reste un beau
gosse alors on oublie que tu as on dit
jean robert par contre les filles
il a énormément de succès bien sûr vous
mettez un gourmand 1 devant devant une
boulangerie où il ya plein de bons
gâteaux il ya un moment donné je suis
diabétique
kaka ne s'est pas droite
jean d'amour sans soucis sans problème
[Musique]
la poubelle
on sent là
on détruit et en 1985 ça tourne au drame
c'est la fameuse affaire chantal nobel
alors dans ce livre c'est la première
fois que sacha distel s'exprime sur
cette affaire et ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'il dit qu'il éprouve toujours
une grande impossibilité en parler vingt
ans après oui mais ça a été très très
très dur une période de
de sa vie très très très dur parce qu'il
ya une une certaine presse qui l'a
entièrement démolie alors qu'il n'y
était pas pour grand-chose bons sont les
choses de la vie ça il dit dans le
bouquin qui se rappellent plus de
l'enchaînement des faits non mais j'ai
des amis qui ont eu des accidents et
effectivement quand il ya une perte de
connaissance on oublie ce qui s'est
passé exactement avant et pendant
il avait perdu la mémoire de de ce qui
s'était passé sur cette route ce soir là
ce qu'il dit à un moment dans l'escalier
je regarde chantait nobel les deux
chiens la porsche le virage et je me
retrouvais l'ailé là allongé mais c'est
bien après oui mais je pense que moi
j'étais pas là mais je pense que c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé
alors pour vous qui prenez les choses
avec une certaine sagesse disons-le à ce
coup là ça doit être dur quand même non
oui sa part été très facile pas été très
facile g
mais c'est à ce moment là que toute la
famille se soudent way et moi en premier
vous l'avez paul et à oui complètement
on est passé à travers et les garçons
étaient formidables aussi et puis mais
ça a duré longtemps quand même on nous a
pas ménagé il raconte une scène assez
terrible si un jour il est à megève
il voit passer chantal nobel qui a du
mal à marcher évidemment ils hésitent à
aller lui parler et c'est pas un manque
de courage d'ailleurs mais mais il va
pas quoi parce qu'il sait pas trop quoi
lui dire mais n'y a pas grand chose à
dire grand chose à dire et c'est navrant
pour elle parce que comme il dit le
tronc d'arbre n'aurait pas été là et
elle n'aurait pas été aussi gravement
blessé ouais et là effectivement sa
carrière en prend un coup il perd le
contact avec le avec le public info ne
pense pas il perd le contact avec le
métier et parce que nous avons reçu
énormément de lettres justement de son
public qui ne comprenaient par ce qui se
passait et je pense pas que le contact
avec le public a été coupée à ce moment
là mais ni lui ni moi n'avons encore
compris pourquoi ça a duré si longtemps
c'est la durée quand même temps moins
disant ouais ça le torturer lui non pas
du tout
torturé trop fort comme on sait
l'ennuyait il se posait des questions ou
saltor lui dit qu'il pensait tous les
jours mais ils pensaient les halles
torture est parent justement parce que
c'est un musicien qui continuait à jouer
sa musique et que et que ça les des
beaucoup alors est ce qu'on va faire
maintenant francine on va écouter
d'abord les chansons de sacha les plus
connus et ensuite celle dont il aurait
aimé qu'elle soit les plus connus didier
e n
le lâche
la montre gypa il est
oh
[Musique]
monsieur carnaval
auj
wouah ça ne peut pas durer comme ça
waouh quel est ce qu'on appelle un tuyau
est on
[Applaudissements]
ma
voilà sacha du ster ça ce sont les
chansons les plus populaires
maintenant on va écouter les quelques
standards du monde hier toute la pluie
tombée sur moi dit d'elle
osamu
sans soucis sans problème
[Musique]
la poubelle
on est triste et ont trait
si longtemps je suis là le coeur battant
roanne plus grand c'est qu'à toi
[Musique]
rakitic
reste pour moi
tu es le soleil de tuer le soleil nommé
joue toute la pluie tendre sur moi et
comme burqa car dans les sous des sons
3 djouba le gallois car
toute la pluie tombe sur moi
tous les toits
à chalon
ce tel effort loyaux qu elle vit aux
escrocs dix ans les one a ici des
esprits
alessi skyblues
là où trois titres
le braille plaide t il
le dax
wah doo hwan de voile à sacha distel
[Applaudissements]
sacha distel disparu en juillet dernier
à l'âge de 71 ans il ne fait pas c'est
incroyable la rétine les gens parce qu'
il est mort jeune pour tout le monde
comme il est tellement beau et bien
conservé c'est incroyable quand tu dis
qu'ils avaient soi c'est déjà ça jean
piat est pareil
l'économie de la vieille dame en
ad'autres la machin qu'on a revu la
semaine dernière il a pris 15 ans là
comme il s'appelait alors gérard darmon
alors ses conquêtes d'un côté votre
fidélité de l'ocha distel a rendu jaloux
beaucoup d'hommes voulu trouviez quoi
vous les femmes à sacha distel interview
voulu trouviez quoi alors est ce que est
ce que sacha par exemple se retenait de
critiquer quand vous ratiez un créneau
par exemple il pourrait pas tellement
donner des leçons de conduite non plus
oui c'est vrai aïe aïe aïe je viens
ratez jamais un créneau est ce que par
exemple c'est le genre de mec à séparer
le blanc des couleurs non hier boucher
le tube de dentifrice
oui et ce qu'ils regardaient du foot en
buvant de la bière non pour savoir ce
que ça nous aide nous ce qu'il faut
faire et pas faire garder n'ont jamais
n'est pas du genre non ils essaient des
mots doux sur le frigo
non car par exemple quand on lui
demandait si on avait grossi disait
toujours non et
disait toujours du bon ouais tu vois
rien y faire est-ce qui sentait bon le
sable chaud et sur tel honneur naissent
à est-ce qu'il offrait des perles de
pluie d'un pays où il ne pleut pas c'est
une phrase que j'adore est-ce que sacha
été fidèle entre deux infidélité bah oui
est-ce qu'ils offraient des fleurs tous
les jours non non est ce qu'il fera a
été trop dur hein est-ce qu'ils
faisaient l'amour comme un dieu
j'ai jamais fait l'amour avec un dieu un
2002 merci vanter d'avoir été avec lui
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
j'accueille michèle laroque gendarmes
ont aidé à nouveau
foi et la religion
vous voulez qu'on commence comme ça peut
être drôle se sent pas les places mais
bon allongée et qu'il sent comme ça va
si on avait dit avant gérard là et dany
ici on change en cours d'émission
si on fait un programme on s'y tient
commence à me casser les couilles cette
histoire et humbert léonard bonsoir
vous êtes ici tous les trois pour [ __ ]
dure le nouveau film de gabriel aghion à
qui on doit déjà [ __ ] douce a cité lui
ouais donc dur il y avoue 3 plus jacques
dutronc sur un scénario de gabriel
aghion et de bertrand blier
le pitch qui fait le pitch mais toi tu
te fasses mauvais non plus alors gérard
et dany vous vivez ensemble vous êtes un
couple installé tout va bien pâques
c'est tout va bien dans votre vie
d'autant plus que vous allez avoir un
enfant un enfant dont gérard et le père
et michel la mère porteuse voilà bien
voilà mais le problème c'est que michel
tombe amoureuse de jacques dutronc
ouais voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
michel après et après ils sont pas
contents du tout les deux pacsés et il
essaie de tout faire foirer
et jacques disparaît voilà et moi je
suis très fâché voilà et je les quitte
voilà avec le bébé qu'est ce qui se
passe après qu'est-ce que je le prends
pas comme ça tout le temps d'accord
bon ça c'était le pitch voulait qu'on
regarde la bande annonce
ah mais si vous voulez vous regardez
tous les trois votre caméra et vous
dites
magnéto serge magnéto serge un ordre
ensemble voilà ça décale tous les places
mais est ce que c'est vrai papa est
homosexuel je vais filmer ça dérange pas
car oui non fethi rejet
oui mon papa est homosexuel on aime moi
j'ai été conçu au bond oui mais comment
j'attends un enfant du plan je suis dans
les trois premiers mois c'est la période
la plus dangereuse qui complètent nos
camps avec décontraction tu n'es pas
enceinte sans penser docteur j'vais vous
presque radicalement les pieds lui
ajouter une petite échographie comme ça
il faudra qu'ils dépensent un teint ça
fait trois mois que j'ai bien danseurs
il est enceinte
[Musique]
et là vous adorez épisode l'homme que
j'aime rencontrer doit déjà vu une mère
se trémousser comme ça elle nous a dit
qu'elle était enceinte retourner à mon
stay vous avez bu avant de venir je suis
le père de cet enfant tu appuies sur un
bouton tu cliques et le poids a fait un
peu plus d'équité selon dos j
l'enfant qui se développe dans le ventre
d'une femme et toi tu vas au gymnase
club tu m'as dit que mes fessiers sur la
chaîne maintenant que tu as fait fuir
l'amant qui me pèse mais on peut quand
même pas le laisser partir avec le
premier venu
pour une fois que je me trouve un hétéro
et je me crois qu'on se marche les [ __ ]
fait on se marre pas tellement
et
ou c'est je pousse bordel je pousse je
pose plus
j'étais sûr qu'ils vont se barrer voilà
[ __ ] beard et gabriel aghion ennemi
ciel largeur d'armand dany boon jacques
dupont voit la sortie le 20 autres corps
alors michel vous après la vie en rose
après [ __ ] douce le placard [ __ ]
dure ça vous excite les noms mais je
c'est vrai que j'ai fait un petit bilan
là je me demande pourquoi j'ai fait tant
de films autour de ce sujet je pense que
je pense que c'est parce que ça parle de
la différence est que et que j'aime bien
justement la tolérance et j'aime bien
qu'on trouve intéressant la différence
et voilà c'est pour ça que j'étais
attiré par ce scénario là un essai c'est
vrai que j'ai eus godrèche nous a
appelés juste avant le tournage pour
vous dire de vous méfier de danic
c'était un mec très égoïste elle est
tombé sur moi donc des gens comme moi
qui ont décroché
car c'est moi qui découvre mais vous il
ya un truc c'est que vous avez rencontré
l'amour sur un plateau de tournage avec
judith vous pensez que ça peut arriver
avec gérard aussi c'est arrivé avec
gérard à dakar ouais pareil
oui on continue à être très chaud du
tout prévu dans le scénario
alors évidemment [ __ ] dure c'est
beaucoup plus violent que [ __ ] douce
c'est l'intrusion de de bertrand blier
qui fait ça c'est beaucoup moins sympa
c'est beaucoup moins gay friendly c'est
violent qu'on veut dire ce que tu dis
gay friendly c'est à dire se serait
montré les homosexuels comme ils ont
envie d'être vu
c'est ça oui voilà dany boon vous êtes
né le 26 juin 66 armentières non mais
c'est un peu c'est un peu quand même là
le parallèle à ces jeux sans détenir
d'un peu d'années
non c'est bon
c'est rien c'est pour une télé régionale
des caméras c'est merci concerne le
cinéma maintenant tu joue dans la cour
des grands battus confie thierry pardon
je voulais pas de couper son prix
continue je vais dire c'est qu'il ya
quand même une je suis dans collision
qui est tout à fait il ya quand même une
collision entre la folie douce deux
avions et la folie dur de haguenau et
vaches un one man show
bien ça me fait plaisir que vous me
posiez cette question laurent parce que
justement ça va se faire la main tenant
à êtes en écriture on peut le dire
y a pas de caméra sur nous c'est pas la
peine pour l'instant c'est vrai bien sûr
que c'est vrai que je me souviens plus
de ce que je veux dire c'est que les
tellement bien que c'est sûr qu'entre
dix ans c'est vrai qu'ici on a pu la
question quand la question c'est qu'il
ya une collision entre la folie douce
d'avion et la folie dur d'oublier en
1989 vous monter à paris il a scellé
premier boulot la période
la galère très difficile très dur de
galère où je faisais pas de télé
régionale et non c'est vrai quoi les
sujets qui sont agendées ya bien un truc
dans ce film c'est qu'une collision hier
soir l'émission elle est diffusée dans
l'émission direct
nous on est sur le régional à l'axé lot
non mais c'est vrai que les sujets
abordés sont restés armentières oui
la région d'amiens sujet les sujets
abordés sont des sujets plus lourd
le dvd du chantier non candidates pour
armentières des sujets mise en place par
jean pierre se rappelle encore les
rapports homos hétéros les rapports
hommes/femmes enfin des des sujets de
société quoi c'est vrai ses oreilles
dany ses oreilles c'est un projet de
carrière ou une malformation on avait
dit gérard et dany c'est la première
fois que vous jouez des homosexuels oui
comme ça oui
moi j'ai fait une fois avec danger la
rote bonsoir merci de passer dans notre
belle région
non il est soudain il est sympa dirigé
mariani j'ai l'impression michel
visualiser un peu dans les films homo
mais c'est la première fois qu'on ait
quoi que ce soit bon pied c'est la
première fois que vous jouez donc tous
les deux des rôles d'homosexuels oui ou
non non moi dans un film de jugnot
j'avais déjà fait ça une fois mais
c'était plutôt une caricature et c'était
sans peur et sans reproche c'est une
caricature il a là c'est vraiment vous
quoi là c'est vraiment moi et puis il ya
eu cet accident de voiture qu'elle
surgit donc tout le monde attendait
alors sinon ça vous plairait dans la vie
je vais essayer d'en régler ces cas
l'accord journée de jetterait pense que
de ce que répond dutronc c'est à dire
que je pense que je ne serai jamais
parce que imagine que j'aime et que
j'adore ça le temps que j'aurais perdu
ouais ça c'est vrai donc je vais pas
essayer et depuis que vous avez fait le
film avec dany vous vous prenez des
douches avec les potes
après le sport on vous a un petit peu
modifiée non s'est il m'arrive de la
fédé d'eau à jardin il pensait la
moustache dany maintenant ça se voit
c'est comment va-t-elle ça pousse pas
j'aime bien ce côté imberbe moindre
oubli dans rabbi jacob avec les riches
hommes c'est l'inoubliable crois qu'on
va voir un extrait
mais y'a un moment même où vous êtes vit
tous les deux si c'était vrai qu'on vive
ensemble ouais non non pas vous je pense
je pense pas puisque enfin je vois que
ça ça fait un peu de peine à nice que je
vais donc oui il ya un moment où j'ai vu
l'avait réellement envisager ce que
j'aime encore un peu toi y est un séquel
michel ta fleur préférée la vie voire
evouna me demande je paye et gris vous
dit m
et vous des menus non c'est pire après
vous seriez open pour des plans à trois
mais comment je me suis open pour des
plans 23 quelle est ta couleur préférée
d'années parce que je suis sur l'autre
chaîne de promo ça c'est de gérer comme
s'est très bien vendu tu actives et je
tenais pas tu n'étais pas chanteur
d'occasion d'un vrai chanteur c'était
par un deuxième album absolue
voila voila ca enregistre laisse j'en
suis là après après le film que je suis
là je vais tourner je vais faire mon
deuxième album et la tournée bientôt
armentières peut-être alors sûrement
chez en ont sûrement chez vous chez vous
à armentières où léa thiry je te rend
l'antenne
merci laurent michel dans la vraie vie
vous partiriez avec lequel des deux sur
une île déserte hc levier ou le léguer
bon
pas facile c'est dommage qu'il soit pas
réussi sur la télé régionale 1 je ne
sais si je ne peux pas avec lequel vous
pourriez dormir dans le même lit sans sa
place quoi que ce soit pourquoi il doit
pas se passer quelque chose sont marqués
par le film c'est lui qui a l'air le
plus marqué puisqu'il a pris vraiment
que dominique segall va être content de
la promotion vous venez de faire la
queue je crois qu'il va être extrêmement
content trois demandes hier c'est très
bon mon mari je sais parce que le film
parle de lui-même de moyens donc on ne
doit pas parler que les convaincre sur
ce film dont vous avez très bien résumé
la situation
une fois guérie tous les trois ans et un
couple pacsé qui acquit qui désirent un
enfant qui est une mère poké une mère je
pense que voilà un cadre assez c'est de
la comédie moi je trouve que la réunion
des deux de l'univers de blier qui était
très très acide et qui a un regard comme
ça
oui sur l'homosexualité c'est assez
pathétique et alors il et il ya aussi
une pathétisme daguillon qui lui le le
transmet avec le rire il aimait bien la
comédie il aime bien
un peu comme c'est râle un peu comme ses
travestis qui sont tout à fait maquiller
quand il se démaquille en dessous c'est
un peu mieux faire influerait belles
images vraiment merci armentières voilà
après leur est bon c'est celle et celle
en vie ou non du du public je pense que
sanaa ce n'est pas du tout la suite je
crois de [ __ ] douce et le deuxième
volet de de [ __ ] douce ses neuf ans
après le monde homosexuel à à bouger à
changer la société a changé c'est autre
chose
alors c'est peut-être un peu plus
grinçant que le premier effectivement il
en parle bien non mais quand on s est
parlé quand armentières tout ça sera
coupée au montage
alors en ce qu on se connaît bien tous
les cadres je vous ai je vous ai souvent
interviewé je vous ai fait un petit peu
toutes les interviews que j'avais alors
malgré tout je suis arrivé comme à
récupérer a récupéré quelques questions
que je vous avais jamais posée ça
s'appelle les questions jamais posée
[Musique]
cette brique et de bras cassés des
questions que j'ai ramassé un peu
partout juste content de votre voiture
oui je vous remercie ou est bien claire
chazal elle vous excite bas maintenant
plus philippe torreton
du coup vous êtes pour l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe
je ne sais pas personne c'est laeticia
je n'en sais rien j'ai seize ce question
pour 18 parce que ouais les arguments ce
qu'ils sont cons 10 noria 70 millions +
majorité musulmane
ça fera 12 12 et quelques pour cent ne
voit on pas aujourd'hui quelle est ta
vision de la corse
on continue vous êtes toujours au parc
des princes pourtant de la pelouse entre
ses mains le chopper plus en tant
qu'acteur en tant que chanteur monroe
c'est kif kif bourricot pareil peu
importe ce que vous dites quoi un peu ça
vous dirait de tourner une fiction pour
tf1
oui on rajoutera des rires montent à 2
par dieu ne faudrait pas qu'il arrête
maintenant le bonheur
ah oui le cake n 1 gérard qu'est-ce que
oui
vous aimeriez qu'on efface quel film de
votre filmographie teulet que j'ai fait
avec giovanni ça s'était très mal passé
entre voilà ça nous met en avant pour la
question plus personnelle sinon aucun
quand on les accepte on y va avec elle
son coeur après vous avez maigri vous
non comme j'ai maigri oui ya cette fois
réussi un régime
vous pensez comme encore devoir se taper
la canicule cet hiver sur le
de toute façon à partir de mon raffin
raffarin a connu la canicule
il était bien évident qu'il n'allait pas
faire chaud oui ça va bien cette flambée
du baril ça vous a fait pas trop réelle
du baril simplement 53 dollars encore ce
matin est ce que ça change au quotidien
dans la vie de star mais au niveau des
chiots de la cuve de fuel aussi votre
chez larousse bon soir c'est la roque à
quoi tu sympa à lire en ce moment en ce
moment qu'est ce qui aurait de sympa à
lire journaux vous car tout cas plutôt
donné raison à l'écolo tous embauchés
le spot mais je passe à la question
sinon je voulais pas le droit mais là je
suis pas émis en ce moment relation les
jeux de pouvoir ok ok d'accord ok ok ok
ok c'est donc un coloriage deuxième
question suivante vous la voulez
monsieur si vous voulez oui comme c'est
à dire que c'est que cette fonction est
fait là celle-là vous la voulez c'est la
question c'est pas comme ça que l'on va
voir
non non non non c'est vous la voulez oui
ou non la première fois que j'ai
rencontré il m'a pas dit vous la voulez
sinon il n'aurait pas eu dany vous avez
écouté nouvel album de sardo nom d'annie
vous avez écouté le nouvel album de dany
nom d'alli vous pensez que ça à baisser
l'immobilier
non ça a demandé michel il vous manque
parfois je dois ça oui beaucoup
voilà la bonne question une belle
réponse oui mais là c'était dire ça
parce que je sais pas exactement
michel il vous manque parfois joe dassin
oui beaucoup
le labo l'avion
avec messieurs
normandin
comme dans le cinéma près de chez vous
alors dany boon vous êtes à l'olympia
oui du 24 novembre 2 janvier oui je
pense que vous allez faire un tabac ça
se présente bien sûr ravi d'être à
l'olympia c'est une salle mythique
d'anissa va alors oui très bien d'une
nouvelle vie nouvelle femme vacances sur
un yacht 1
et puis cette patate toujours non
pourquoi je suis prêt à les suivre en
vacances sur un yacht
moi je les ai vus dans voici sur un
yacht un nom à traverser un ponton ouais
bah c'est joli comme légende l'a fait
dany boon travers ces retours dont sabah
pour la fille donc l'olympia le 24 nov
thierry ardisson bonsoir bonsoir c'est
la sixième année septième année de
toulouse septième année est-ce que
parfois ou vous n'approuvez pas des
moments de lassitude pas du tout non
j'ai toujours la même pâte a toujours
les mêmes patate
au début oui mais on va regarder tueries
continuent on vous suit armentières 1-0
en deuil mais la patate quand même
michèle laroque bourse vous avez tourné
de notre premier film américain
ah oui aussi c'est quoi ce film
américain alors c'est j'ai acheté les
droits de deux
livre un lit français qui s'appelait
pitt chercheurs avaient déjà par une
bombe toujours en train d'essayer de
développer et aussi j'ai acheté un livre
anglais qui s'appelle les droits d'un
livre qui s'appelle don't you want me in
the night et c'est une comédie
romantique très sympathique ça que je
voudrais faire là bas
voilà qui regardent ils sont bons ce
soir et pourquoi cette envie du prime
time toujours revenir au times
ça vous suffit pas cette émission si je
pense que ça me suffit alors pourquoi
vous faites des prime time mais pourquoi
tu fais des prime time je sais pas t'as
pas envie d'arrêter ces primes tard ici
alors dit de la caméra vasily carton
coeur dix mois les prime time j'arrête
mais on arrête c'est pour ça que c'est
moins drôle bien écouter l'info n'était
pas parvenu à monter la tuerie je suis
désolé pour cette gamme est ce que est
ce que dominique segall est content
catherine sur le tennis vient mais je
crois qu'il s'est pendu dans la loge qui
arrive bien gilbert bécaud je trouve
c'est bien alors carcela à l'eau
oui
françois lamy bonsoir atomique
je voulais savoir si vous étiez content
de la façon dont ils ont vendu le film
s'il avait oublié quelque chose auquel
cas nous pourrions leur ajouter je ne
vaux rien oui je ne vous revient
il en a bien parlé gérard les mois mais
lui à la fin c'est denis et moi j'étais
plus sur les denrées l'errance munich ce
galeux bonsoir je vous connais très peu
en province est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter
je suis qu'un attaché de presse du team
alors lui envieraient bien parler du
canal afin qu'il a repris la parole
c'est oui parce que je le dirai à
michelle com comment tu as trouvé michel
la prestation de michel à non parce que
j'ai dormi avant de venir
ah oui et personne ne va là ça y est tu
vois un coup d'électrochocs bon je vous
laisse maintenant merci on va merci
il ya dans notre jeu
[Musique]
et maintenant c est
j'ai raté j'ai raté ça c'est le direct
c'est une plante du plantain s'est
défini ses sacs et chaussons qu'on peut
rien rattrapé celle de son fils elle est
maintenant on sait
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'accueille monseigneur di falco et
frédéric beigbeder
c'est l'autre pas dans ses notes changer
juste non je dirais plutôt la ferme où
tu veux pas mettre monseigneur di falco
à côté de la route quand même laurent
bon il saura résister à la tentation
j'imagine un stade où tout est difficile
ça ne me gênerait pas du tout bien jean
michel di falco bonsoir ex porte parole
des évêques de france
un jour j'avais mon seigneur des courges
et égarement excusez moi mon seigneur
mais j'invite et d'armand à dîner à la
maison et il y avait le conduit de la
morandais il y avait le biographe du
capot c'est donc au niveau des vannes
c'était assez là j'ai réalisé lors
disant ça que ce soir je relis toi
désolé non mais là rien contre l'église
catholique un gérard du tout voilà alors
jean-michel di falco
l'ex porte parole des évêques de france
aujourd'hui évêque de gap 1
vous êtes un homme un homme de dieu
j'essaie c'est pas frustrante travailler
pour quelqu'un qu'on voit jamais parfois
c'est plus facile alors frédéric
beigbeder bonsoir auteur à succès
notamment de 99 francs de windows on the
world
cris interallié 2003 éditeur chez
flammarion
tout à fait thierry et puis voilà et
puis vous collaborez un certain nombre
de deux journaux voilà qui est venons
pas voilà voici et oui vous publié tous
les deux je crois moi non plus chez
calmann-lévy donc j'étais un dialogue
entre un évêque et un mécréant
c'est ça voilà oui parce que je pense
qu'il est important
on critique beaucoup l'islam mais est
important aussi de critiquer le
catholicisme
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on s'en
prennent toujours à la même religion
voilà alors en fait c'est pas votre
première rencontre vous êtes connu il ya
longtemps
à l'époque en 1974 la ligne on peut y
lire
non c'est j'ai un assistant qui me fait
des blagues il va devenir bien leonardo
n'ont en fait en fait que des remakes bd
jean michel di falco se sont rencontrés
à l'école bossuet dont vous étiez le
directeur et vous frédéric vous étiez
l'élève sait comment briand à la chanson
trop se fatiguer ah ouais ouais nan la
meilleure ça c'est les prévient louis
péries dénis bouan il était qualité c
est ce qu il était déjà très excité
comme ça oui oui je ressors grosse
saison zébulon et vous frédéric vous
trouviez comment monseigneur di falco à
l'époque je ne trouvais plus cool que
les curés qui l'a remplacé à bossuet il
y avait avant lui des prêtres assez
sévère et lui était plus
moderne bon c'était après mai 68 je veux
boucher les oreilles pour être plus
libre
tu vas dire alors frédéric vous avez
fait votre catéchisme vous avez était
enfant de choeur vous apportez une aube
c'est vrai c'est vrai et et à 16 17 ans
vous avez tout envoyer balader
ben comme beaucoup de gens c'est à dire
que ans
on grandit on est éduqué dans la
chrétienté tous appuyé un moment on
oublie et puis où on retrouve ça
ennuyeux ou faux ou ridicule ou
mensongers ouais et autant de reproches
que j'ai voulu exprimer exprimer en face
de la personne qui finalement était
responsable de tout ça depuis vous êtes
dans l'athéisme forcé les noms moi je
dis il ya peut-être quelque chose mais
je sais pas quoi ouais voilà voilà
et c'est un peu le cas à mon avis de la
majeure partie des gens ils sont venus
ce tic sans le savoir
mais vous avez quand même à l'église
pour les mariages les enterrements vous
êtes pratiquant sans être croyant
exactement oui oui j'ai même fait
baptiser ma fille pour qu'elle puisse
choisir plus tard son camp mais vous
dites quand même qu'on finit par se
lasser de la dérision du du cynisme et
qu'on se demande si c'est pas quelque
chose c'est le centre de ce
chef-d'oeuvre c'est de dire que
au fond pendant pendant pas mal de temps
et dans plusieurs livres
j'ai expliqué que j'étais une liste que
j'étais cynique j'ai décrit des
personnages paumés et c'est un peu bidon
à mon avis de dire qu'on est nul ici on
se flinguent pas un donc si on se
flinguent pas et qu'on fait comme moi
c'est à dire qu'en plus on donne la vie
il faut vraiment s'interroger sur ce
qu'on fait là voilà donc ce que fera ce
formidable fredericks et il m'arrive
d'avoir des doutes sur l'inexistence de
dieu
donc voilà reid pascal aussi qui est
important ouais ouais bien sûr
pascal sellem qui est quand même donc là
à la fois l'autre pas ce qui n'empêche
pas chacun de doute et voilà ce qu'on
pourrait dire du oui cela commence par
seconde mon père même si vous n'êtes que
vous doutez vous dites mais même le
christ sur la croix à douter oui le pape
doit douter je suis sûr je pense que
fois c'est quelque chose de vivant et
donc le doute peut la traverser
ouais tu suis pas tout à fait il me
demande si chez d ecstasy a patiné en
train de travailler jeu s'il avait lu le
livre on dit mon père vous dites comme
vous voulez moi je dis ma couille à
m'encourager pas
mais un diamantaire on peut le dire
c'est mon père on peut le dire d'accord
dans qui disent monseigneur un évêque
oui moi je fais mon seigneur
personnellement si tu veux on a déjà eu
des monseigneur way we alors pour
frédéric dieu est une invention des
hommes et pour vous les hommes sont une
invention de dieu oui je trouve que
c'était au départ une très belle idée un
de dire tout ça a un sens plutôt coquin
de dire que l'amour est possible que
quelqu'un quelque part un esprit a tout
organisé idée magnifique mais les hommes
en ont fait quelque chose de terrible et
qui a qui continuent de causer des
dégâts hier des millions de morts
voilà donc c'est un peu énervant aussi
michel est d'accord sans exprimer
qui est responsable la guerre est ce que
c'est dieu ou est ce que ce sont les
hommes c'est pas dieu qui fait la guerre
sont les hommes
alors il y en a qui prétendent la faire
au nom de dieu mais c'est une trahison
de dieu voilà j'ai des rares vrais
réagir c'est un livre c'est un livre ça
discute un livre on discute beaucoup
il ya un prix nobel portugais qui
s'appelle
josé saramago qui regrette que dieu ne
soit pas mort comme l'avait dit
nietzsche
parce que finalement bleus en septembre
on s'est aperçu que l'idée de dieu
pouvait tuer énormément il est même que
que récemment c'est sans rejoint ce
qu'on disait l'instant c'est que agir au
nom de dieu dans le mal
c'est une trahison il n'est pas avoir
compris qui est dieu pardon mon père
mais j'aimerais qu'on revient au sujet
si vous le permettez je vous en prie ah
c'était le sujet on me dit dans
l'oreillette ce qu'est ce qui est drôle
c'est que frédéric vous programmez votre
votre athéisme aurez vous dit vous ne
croyez pas en dieu mais il faisait site
définir un peu l'idée de dieu vous dites
ces étals de grâce dans lequel me plonge
ma fille où l'état de grâce dans lequel
me plonge l'acte sexuel et il vous dit
bah c'est ça c'est dieu est amour
finalement c'est l'amour que vous avez
pour votre fille l'amour que vous avez
pour les femmes ce cas ce que vous
ressentez quand vous c'est ça je dieu
finalement mais avait rencontré sans le
savoir
peut-être c'est une question de
vocabulaire j'espère que si on appelle
ça le hasard ou l'amour ou
le sens à ce moment là je suis prêt à
croire en dieu
ce que j'ai remarqué en tout cas dans
notre conversation et on le voit dans le
livre c'est qu'à partir du moment où on
a parlé de la fille de frédéric ouais il
y avait un changement d'attitude des
réactions ce qui montre bien que le fait
d'être d'avoir la responsabilité d'un
enfant change tout car le chacun son
sacre élevé d'avoir donné la vie cela
responsabilise et ça nous oblige à
entrevoir autre chose mais c'est même
plus plus physique que ça c'est à dire
quand on quand on on vous met quelqu'un
dans les bras il se passe quelque chose
qui est supérieur à l'être humain et une
fille étaient truquées presque voilà qui
est spirituel qui est bizarre qui est
encore plus fort que de la drogue
non c'est possible c'est bon de le voir
parler comme ça reste bien aujourd'hui
parce qu'on l'a entendu tenir un autre
discours
voilà c'était très beau jeu mais tu sais
que charles de foucauld le père de
foucauld de jean-pierre non le père du
couteau le père de foucauld c'était un
fêtard incroyable et ça chante ici dans
le désert il est parti dans le désert au
sud de l'algérie tout seul le semaine au
club on parle beaucoup de ça on parle
des rebelles voulaient tous les fêtards
qui sont devenus des mois et où qui est
l inverse
voilà alors à vous parler c'est l'avis
de son j'ai eu droit et de la mort alors
évidemment vous comme vous croyez pas
mon cher frédéric ça doit être terrible
pour vous parce que la mort est à rien
après pour vous non plus dur c'est vrai
que c'est plus dur pour pour quelqu'un
qui n'est pas croyant c'est bien plus
dur chez la mort c'est la fin de tout et
tout s'arrête donc d'entre vie est un
compte à rebours exactement la vie
c'est ça une durée limitée et il se
passera après à moins que par le
truchement de la littérature on puisse
connaître une vie après la mort
impossible d écoute talent vous n'êtes
pas d'accord monseigneur par rapport à
ça bien sûr donc qu'est-ce qui après la
mort très brièvement marianne paradis
investi ma foi me fait me dire que il y
a la plénitude qu'on trouve en dieu
et puis le bonheur de trouver aussi ce
qu'on a perdu qu'on a aimé que l'on
retrouve à ce moment là mais ça c'est ma
foi c'est mon espérance en tout cas donc
vous vous êtes pas triste de mourir
de même content dans ma propre mort ne
préoccupe pas si votre mort me préoccupe
assez la mienne qui moi je les dirai de
métro
qu'est ce que tu penses qu'il ya après
la mort qui a encore quelque chose ou
que l'on devient la poussière je pense
très fermement qu'il ya autre chose mais
quoi comme un complexe sportif tu vois
comment t'y city joe hart 10 4 11 aces
le plein c'est quoi l'amour est ce que
c'est la mauvaise lumière quelque chose
qui me suis alors vous parlez de la mort
vous parler aussi du du pape évidemment
et vous avez la bonne réponse évidemment
le pape il n'est pas là pour dire fait
l'amour dans la rue tous ensemble etc
voilà mais l'histoire du préservatif il
l'a jamais dit non voilà c'est important
on le dit on le redit on le redit ça
fait partie des moments où ils me claque
le beignet parce que je savais moi non
moi je c'est vrai que je là je
colportait
présent sur le web
voilà alors évidemment le pape c'est pas
quelqu'un qui va dire aux gens en fait
tout ce que vous voulez exergue c'est
sûr il prône plutôt la fidélité c'est
normal c'est le pape
bon ça serait bizarre si les autres
choses mais en même temps il n'a jamais
dit ne mettez pas de préservatif en
afrique pour attraper le sida il l'a
jamais en plus sinon que ce que j'allais
vous dire c'est que il se trouve que
j'étais à rome la semaine dernière que
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le pape
et qu'il habituellement effet un cadeau
alors j'ai remarqué que vous dans vos
émissions généralement vous n'en faites
pas non jean ferré moi je vous en ai
apporté la voilà du pape
et si vous n'en avez pas lusage merci
mais je suis sûr que vous trouverez
quelqu'un à qui se fera parce qu'il soit
bâti merci beaucoup
ce cas nous c'est notre cas nous on
il est merveilleux parce que je m y
marquent bien sa déception je sais qu'il
avait commandé une game boy
il est détenu et finalement il accepte
ou shadow merci merci pour ce chapelet
monseigneur merci beaucoup
lorsque jean michel di bacco pour la
première fois dans cette émission il
m'avait passé sans collier de chien là
et pikachu
c'était on en arrive justement aux
signes ostentatoires mais le voile à
vous avez vu que l'accord ge qui
accueille il ya un collège il ya un
collège à toulon où on a interdit à un
prêtre de venir en soutane en lui
expliquant que c'était un signe
ostentatoire
c'est dingue d'un coup là oui mais en
fait il faudrait connaître davantage en
détail ce cette affaire là parce que
c'est pas qu'il n'ya pas que cette
question il ya d'autres choses plus
compliquées mais c'est vrai que ça
devient complètement ridicule je crois
que là la conception d'une laïcité scène
ce n'est pas de demander à chacun de ne
pas être ce qu'il est mais c'est
d'apprendre à s'accepter telles que nous
sommes en nos différences bon or le
discours qui concerne la laïcité
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est surtout ne
soyez pas ce que vous êtes alors en
revanche c'est vrai que peut-être il
faut protéger ceux qui voudraient
imposer à être ceci ou de cela mais si
on n'apprend pas à l'école à se
respecter différents mais on apprend
quand vous êtes contre la loi vous oui
oui pour moi j'ai pas tué pour toi
pourquoi un signe mais tu peux t'en
c'est michel c'est compliqué déjà 60 il
allait en toi c'est que tu es pour cette
loi à frédéric moi je crois que c'est
laid
les musulmans démocrates libéraux
réclamaient cette loi parce que c'est
les aident à combattre et intégristes et
moi je te dis que d'ici quelques mois
nous verrons que cette loi va provoquer
encore plus de difficultés qu'il y en
avait avant il fallait laisser est donné
les moyens proviseur de régler ces
problèmes et pas faire une loi
je crois que dany veut réagir d'amis moi
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose après la
mort alors qu'ils délèguent quelque
chose après le sommet c'est
extraordinaire parce que tu es pour la
loi toi là les signes ostentatoires
instinctivement j'avais envie de dire
exactement ce que vous disais c'est à
dire qu'on dont on doit ré c'est ce
qu'on est à partir d enfin je suis pour
la laïcité mais mais avoir représenté ce
conte et ne signifie pas vouloir
convaincre les autres mais voilà mais on
m'a expliqué qu'il fallait absolument
faire passer cette loi alors je sais
plus quoi cracher plus non
gérard tuer pour la loi sur les signes
ostentatoires
c'est à traiter au cas par cas je pense
pas qu'une loi sa global soit soit mais
c'est un peu le péché mignon de la
france de faire des lois pour très bien
merci
non mais c'est bien bravo
pardon oui je suis contre je suis contre
les radiateurs dans les classes a
bousillé toute ma scolarité et
maintenant
maintenant nous allons parler de
l'homoparentalité qui était le sujet qui
nous a occupés tout au tout au long de
cette émission puisque comme vous le
savez mon père gérard michel et dani
sont à l'affiché d'un film qui s'appelle
[ __ ] dure qui était un film sur
l'homoparentalité donc ils ont un enfant
ensemble que porte que porte michel vous
ce que vous dites c'est qu'en fait vite
pas si vous êtes pour ou contre vous
dites que on manque de recul aujourd'hui
on sait pas très bien il n'y a pas
d'exemple sur des longues périodes
on ne sait pas très bien ce qui va se
passer pour ces enfants c'est qu'ils
sont élevés par deux papas exado marrant
d'ailleurs du canard aux états unis il
ya des études qui ont été faites
réunis à san francisco oui et où on
montre que les enfants qui ont été
adoptées vont beaucoup mieux maintenant
qu'ils sont adolescents que des enfants
qui sont restés à leur félina j'avais
des maternelles qui sont pas de la gare
homosexuels et mon père vous êtes pour
le mariage des prêtres
entre eux c'est bien parce que vous
posez des questions où il n'y a pas de
raison c'est quoi
ces questions là et où mon père est ce
que je serai de pardonner pour toutes
ces conneries c'est ça la religion
catholique est un petit monde flippe la
flip sa race on pourra se parler après
votre disposition on dit qu'à pas assez
de recul pour savoir faire et notre part
on pense mais en effet on n'a pas assez
de recul mais que pour l' équilibre d'un
enfant c'est important qu'il ya une mère
et un père c'est là qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il dit ça mais il dit aussi
dans le livre qu'il a baptisé 60 pour un
couple homo ah oui donc dans [ __ ] dure
il aurait pu baptiser le parce qu'il n'y
a aucune y'a pas de raison que si
l'église ne l'admets pas cette situation
là c'est à dire un couple de deux hommes
ou deux femmes
s'ils ont un enfant et qui souhaite lui
donner une éducation chrétienne et qui
s'adresse à l'église en disant on veut
que cette enfant soit baptisé je vois
pas au nom de quoi on pénaliserait
l'enfant parce que les parents ou en
tout cas ceux qui s'en occupent sont pas
dans une situation que l'église a admis
comme père et une mère pour un enfant
mais si un enfant était abandonnée dans
un orphelinat et qu' il y danser il
reste dans cet orphelinat sans amour
sans attention j'ai avoir eu peur que
rien oui oui de mer
oui vaut mieux être élevé par deux
homosexuels formidable que des parents
peut-être qu'ils se foutent sur la
gueule de john reid
mais je suis assez des situations assez
cool mon père non même temps c'est pas
lui qui est cool c'est l'église
catholique qui est très tolérante
laurent sage elle a bien évolué parce
qu'il ya quand même eu des périodes
sombres 2000 ans d'histoire est de fait
de milan de couples hétéros beaucoup de
dégâts t'en parle d'ailleurs toit du
couple hétéro un an tu dis bon
effectivement les changes il sait bien
mais en même temps je suis très jaloux
enfin ensemble ça te la tourmente un cd
questions qui touchent aussi je crois
mais bien sûr non c'est surtout le le
mariage royal et nous esquissons parle
du mariage du mariage c'est un acte
religieux et
et c'est vrai que mois après avoir
divorcé j'ai refait ce pari qui n'est
pas peut-être comme le pari de pascal
mais qui est un autre pari bien
conclusion du truc en tous les cas la
fin du bouquin frédéric vous n'êtes pas
converti ne vais pas arriver le père
avons converti c'était pas le but
ouais ouais non n'a pas converti mais je
pense que c'est des vrais qu'est ce qui
t'as un peu ébranlé quand même
m
on en discute a pas bien de faire ça
tout à fait réfléchir
bien sûr mais on voit aussi j'espère moi
ça me fait réfléchir aussi est-ce qui
vous a fait douter une il ne m'a pas
fait douter mais je crois que ce qui m'a
passionné dans ce livre c'est justement
de la rencontre de deux univers qui
n'ont pas de raison de se rencontrer mon
père dernière question pourquoi j'ai pas
de cadeaux moi même cadeau bien jeu
pourquoi moi pourquoi lui a droit alors
les gens n'avaient avec une magen david
voilà le cadeau à ce gentil père
je crois
les jeunes
fédérer
et
si vous n'en avez pas usage je suis sûr
que vous connaissez quelqu'un qui sait
pas si on a tous un ami
croyant sa frappe les îles a absolument
former 20 ans mais c'est bien mon père
de donner un cadeau qu'on a reçues s'est
pas empêché sont en cours
interview je crois moi non plus est ce
que vous croyez en dieu
soyez surpris que je vous dise le
contraire frédéric
non mais j'y travaille dany moi je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose après le sommeil
et moi je crois en ligne yang
mais on les recevra la semaine prochaine
ça c est ce que vous croyez au diable oh
que oui
ah oui toi ya une phrase de cioran qu'on
cite qui qui dit il dit si dieu
gouvernent le monde
on n'y comprend rien par contre si c'est
le diable qui règne tout s'explique
est ce que vous croyez au miracle de
jésus oui puisqu'ils continuent à y en
avoir il ya des miracles aujourd'hui
avéré oui on est toujours là thierry oui
ça c'est déjà fait et on en dit des
conneries
est ce que vous croyez que jésus est
avec marie-madeleine même nom le dit
beaucoup dans la ville chico dont le
design chic bloody un oui oui non mais
je les lui justement oui c'est pour ckoi
pas grave et là dessus je me suis un peu
ennuyé en lisant ce livre et je me
demande qu'est ce qui fait son succès
vous croyez qu'il n'était pas avec
marie-madeleine g2 non non mais c'est en
mon père même s'il a été avec marie
madeleine où est le problème
non mais c'est pas le sujet est ce que
tu crois à l'homéopathie toi
à petit nom mais je crois en l effet les
l'espèce
senna est ce que vous croyez votre femme
quand elle vous dit que vous êtes le
plus beau gerard eux
j'ai parfois la vanité de la croix rouge
oui ça peut arriver mais génie moi je
crois qu'elle le croyait
est ce que tu crois au paradis michel
oui c'est comment alors c'est ce que
j'ai envie de créer moi à oui à chacun
se crée son paradis je devrai comment
est ce qu'il ya une pièce principale
parce que je sais que c'est élise et le
cap d'agde c'est à peu près ça est ce
que tu crois frédéric que dieu a besoin
d'un conseil en marketing
non mais il a il a embauché son fils qui
était assez fort quand même
moi je crois qu'il a surtout besoin
d'amour laurent est ce que tu crois aux
tables qui tourne non dany est ce que tu
crois au big bang ha oui oui bien sûr
mais je dormais quand c'est arrivé
et oui bien sûr et aux tables qui tourne
aussi a aussi oui pendant le big bang à
l'apocalypse nucléaire
oui c'est possible mais bon mais il ya
un film dans les années soixante dix la
dessus sur l'apocalypse nucléaire et
c'est le diable tout ça c'est du diable
bu du thé pas grave et jacob la
réincarnation mon père non mais c'est
pas on n'a pas le droit nous dit quoi si
vous voulez y croire ah non moi je suis
catholique et tout ce qu'il faut faire
est ce que vous croyez à la colonisation
de mars frédéric beigbeder je pense que
dans une centaine d'années la planète
terre sera trop étroite et qu'il faudra
le niger et marc seulement mars
oui la lune ouais bien sûr me to the
moon puis koné toilettes meet you man 2
thor est ce que tu crois le météo
d'evelyne des violons oui moi je me les
repas ce nom qui s'est par exemple la
météo du 17 janvier dernier un jeu mais
un repas souvent c'est une superbe météo
pour un mois de janvier 1
est ce que tu crois avait fait des
crèmes amincissantes
bah ça marche
spécifiques ah ouais c'est trouver tout
nouveau j'ai fait un gym spécifique moi
j'ai perdu deux kilos en hauteur étaient
gros comme ça c'est gros comme ça qu'est
ce que tu crois aux chaussettes blanches
avec des mocassins
malheureusement ça existe y'a pas y
croire c'est je crois moi non plus jean
michel
[Musique]
merci d'avoir été avec nous monseigneur
merci beaucoup et bravo d'avoir d'abord
avec ses petites discuter avec ce
mécréant bon nombre qu'en même temps ça
a pris trois ans non
oui mais les supports et ce pendant
trois ans oui m'enfin c'est pas tous les
jours
[Musique]
et maintenant mimi coin de retrouver la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rhinite mano mano
principales aires via golino
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
valeria golino venez c'est tout le monde
ici j'imagine oui je connais je les ai
connu mieux
en attendant ouais ben hogan et ses
erreurs bien sûr je savais qu'il allait
bien jacob est ce que tu connais ma mère
ya golino gérard wey à la loge de la
rode dany boon laurent baffie avec
beigbeder voilà alors valeria est une
actrice italienne à la carrière
internationale mais c'est vrai que
depuis quelques temps vous recentrez un
petit peu votre votre carrière sur la
france avec san antonio
36 quai des orfèvres qui n'est pas
encore sorti qu'il va bientôt sortir par
la suite de 37 2 le matin ramenant
lorsque les gens vont confondre
et aujourd'hui vous êtes ici pour le
live de frédéric berthe voilà donc trois
films français coup sur coup on peut
dire dans un an
voilà alors là il va avec richard
anconina et vous sortie le 20 octobre
vous voulez que je fasse le pitch bien
sûr s'il te plait merci à lui
alors c'est l'histoire d'un metteur en
scène de comédie musicale à succès qui
est tellement occupé que sa femme l'a
quitté
elle a refait sa vie de son côté et lui
n'a plus rien fait voilà et là il va
tout donner pour remonter un spectacle
et surtout reconquérir le coeur de sa
femme vous qu'il aime toujours voilà
voilà voilà l'histoire
alors maintenant après le pitch et a
toujours la bande-annonce ces rituels
alors valeria vous regardez votre caméra
c'est le yale rouge et vous dit tenir
magnéto sérgio maggie deux magnétos
sergio
alors c'est toi même j'ai un projet
d'habitude une comédie musicale
tous s inquiète beaucoup
bon j'ai monté le spectacle tout ça je
vais trouver des jeunes je ferai les
auditions gelé formeraient je ne sais
pas peut-être madelin partout qui peut
parler de jeu nous une comédie musicale
et je cherche son compositeur vous aviez
retenu parmi plus de 200 jeunes artistes
où
toujours un moment très difficile de
choisir mais voilà c'est fait c'est vous
je sais qu'ils n'ont pas d'expérience
c'est l'espoir du monde une chose
me faire confiance dans la musique qui
fait quoi je pense que la musique c'est
tout ce que je sais faire correctement
et je crois que c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse
il est souvent bien seul à tous s'il
continue comme ça il va passer à côté de
petites choses
non messieurs de ski français
tu m'avais dit chanterait pas
apparemment tu puisses pas alors
j'arrête tout simplement ça me regarde
et qui lui fait de mes lettres pour
monter un spectacle c'est ça alex
suspect d'âge c'était pour toi volet
petit teckel droit tout permet d'étaler
mes sentiments
aucune chance mathieu s'est apprécié de
ton père t'a pris mes liens
[Musique]
d'octobre ça va pas du tout le secret
toujours le coeur gravé ça doit être
fakhro up&net première place
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
frédéric berthe avec richard anconina et
valeriya
ok notre invité ce soir voilà alors
c'est en fait c'est anconina qui a pensé
à vous et ils vous connaissez c'est lui
qui a demandé aux producteurs de vous
contacter vue qui vous a découverte en
fait dans rain man quand j'aurai avec
avec tom cruise au sélénium un excellent
de wever n'a pas vu le film
non c'est pas ça mais j'étais en train
de parler se supporte plus ce que s'il
veut la garde des gosses qui est quoi ca
ses avocats en ce moment ils sont comme
ça donc c'est richard anconina qui a
qu'à penser à vous c'est lui qui vous a
découverte
ouais j'avais de ma faute c'est de ma
faute
tête de reproches des ministres s'est
réuni après
donc c'est richard anconina qui a pensé
à vous ils vous avez vu en fait dans
rain man
juillet avec tom cruise bonne cause bien
sûr
donc il vous a invité avoir un coup à
l'hôtel raphaël et là c'était terrible
parce qu'après tom cruise donc vous
tombez sur richard anconina même la
désintoxication il était timide non il
était hyper timide serein non la vérité
c'est qu'il avait vu ses films que je
vais fait en italie respiro symbolique
il était sorti en prince
il avait quelques semaines il avait vu
les films et juste après il est venu me
voir en fin de l'été oui il peut retenir
c'est vrai il ment il a rien dit ils
essayent de vous expliquer film en fait
il n'y est pas arrivé quand il était
complètement fascinée par vous non j'y
suis même pas si c'était ça mais je
crois que les timides toujours d'amis
avec les femmes riches au lait tu vois
c'est ça aussi son charme je vois
derrière vous avez été obligé de grossir
pour le rôle non j'étais j'avais déjà
grossi c'était déjà un crédit pour un
autre rôle et je suis resté ce que j'ai
cherché des magrets mais j'ai pas eu le
temps
j'arrivais vous avez drôlement alors dû
la gg récompensés mais c'est toujours
facile de grossir parce que c'est c'est
bien alors ce qu'il faut savoir quand
même c'est que valeria a été victime
d'une d'une scoliose et enfants et la
lordose aussi qu'être angels la cyphose
la surdose
l'overdose
donc alors vous avez été opéré ça vous a
pas empêché d'être d'être mannequin
d'ailleurs cette scoliose et cette
opération oui mais vous avez eu
longtemps encore le morceau de fer dans
le dos un oui j les unes pendant sept ou
huit ans et après j'ai eu aussi un
accident
cette hogra j'avais oublié de retirer le
papier dans les chaussures pendant une
semaine j'ai planché avec ses pas pour
mener les choses à moi mais tout le
monde a souffert à cette table bien
michel aussi michel a eu un accident de
voiture
alexandre voiture elle est restée et
beaucoup de gens je vais vous dire j'ai
remarqué que beaucoup de gens que
j'interviewe sont des gens qui ont eu un
accident jeunes et qui sur le lit vous
pensez en faisant herbert léonard qui va
nous rejoindre j'espère herbert léonard
il a commencé la guitare parce qu'il
était sur un lit toi tu as commencé à
t'intéresser à la comédie parce que tu
étais sur un lit rocco pareil il
s'intéressait c'est vrai il ya des
votations donc balearia
et mannequin et puis un jour à à l'âge
de 16 ans votre oncle vous présente lina
wertmüller qui était la réalisatrice
importante les années 70 et vous faites
un film avec hugo toc nassi voila voila
c'était un de mes acteurs préférés tout
mon enfance et mon adolescence il a un
grain d'actair voit là encore c'est une
musique bien sûr
donc voila vous commencez avec nous fait
plein de films ensuite on vous retrouve
à hollywood et là vous êtes la fiancée
donc de tom cruise au cinéma mais dans
la vraie vie c'est pas mal non plus
puisque notre ami valeria était la
fiancée de zdar menez on peut
l'idéologue de benicio del toro a le
goût il sait quoi c'est pas vrai ces
musulmans vous le saviez pas
c'était benicio del toro et je vous dis
bravo
il est à noter vous raté de peu le rôle
de julia roberts dans pretty woman
ouais mais c'est toujours
c'était un mur dans pourquoi vous l'avez
pas eu le rôle parce qu'elle était mieux
que moi c'est mais c'est vrai quand même
du mois j'étais bien amerell elle était
mieux en mieux se prêter au même prix
quand même moment on était les derniers
mais on peut toujours adaptés voilà et
un jour donc vous habiter là-bas
hollywood et un jour j'en ai marre de
hollywood
alors là c'est très intéressant parce
que michel m'a quitté pour aller
s'installer à hollywood
bah je sais que tu reviens heureusement
que tu reviens parce que voilà ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'en fait valeria une
grande maison une piscine une assistante
quand il s'est rendu compte elle s'est
rendue compte qu'elle travaillait en
fait pour payer ça et elle s'est dit
mais qu'est-ce que je m'emmerde à
travailler pour payer tout ça voilà pour
payer le confort et s'est dit finalement
si j'avais pu tout ce confort je serais
beaucoup plus libre audacieux mais c'est
pas que je me marre de rouler ou de ces
genres des jeunes non je n'ai mangé
j'adorerais d'être et travailler dans
des films américains mais pas vivre man
toi quand tu es très jeune tu touring
toi c'est très très bien partout un
certain moment tous cherchent le racing
va voir si vous êtes italienne
on va vous faire une interview série
talent
[Musique]
beria est ce que vous mangez des packs
tous les jours voilà presque
est ce que vous savez faire les pattes
voilà bien sûr vous les fait comment ces
trois questions 1 question des normes et
les fait comment
combien et quand des noms combien de
minutes ça dépend de la partie ça dépend
de la pâte toute façon tous là sans
danger tout même façon après tout quoi
je voulais stimuler ses dérivés toni
s'est terminée par le long d'une route
dans le brouillard est ce mieux qu il
faut pour les jeter au mur les pattes
si ça colle c'est que c'est vrai qu'en
même temps qu'elle fasse comme les
petits bonhommes sur le mur du sénat tôt
alors on a moins comme ça
si vous êtes une vraie rick hallet ce
que vous conduisez n'importe comment en
klaxonnant tout le temps parfois là non
parce que j'ai appris à conduire à los
angeles
oui mais là j'ai comme une vieille dame
j'ai des gros seins c'est d'accord est
ce qu est ce qu ont baladés est ce
qu'une balade énorme sur une question
aussi des questions idiotes la réponse
par mois est-ce que vous balader en
scooter dans les rues de rome
oui ça c'est les vrais rayons les feux
rouges sans canne après 5h à naples on
s'arrête pas aux feux rouges avec le
foulard nouées son bac en soi même c'est
beau est ce que vous trouvez berlusconi
sympathique
voilà il fait rire quand il a son truc
sur la tête
un ferry est ce que vous êtes de famille
aux usa et voilà encore tous les
italiens ont la famille comme des
immigrants
est-ce que vous parler avec les mains je
parle avec les mains et bab données sur
la table s'il vous plaît merci
est ce que quand vous serez marié vous
vous laisserez aller c'est possible
c'est est-ce que vous insultez dieu vous
blesse fait mais beaucoup plus éminents
non excusées un membre de votre famille
qui fait partie de la mafia
non deux membres
je vais vous est croyante croyante
pas vraiment mais mes pas me pas avec
légèreté
tu vois c'est pas que je suis simplement
d' pas croyante je voudrais bien hein ça
vous manque
ça ça me plaisait d'avoir 7 voilà
comment des aides oued
est-ce que vous n'êtes qu'à précieuse un
peu cheap et un petit peu comme richard
anconina qui sort le 20 mai
ap
la bande originale de mindello son
slogan d'hôtel
dans cette chanson
tout via mon ti amo
la météo comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ardant catherine ça t'a fait des bonds à
livre ouvert
là c'est bon déjà il s'imagine viennent
rouler un patin michèle laroque à
valeria golino sans faire mention du
nombre assez d'armand sur la bouche
depuis [ __ ] dure il adore sa bonne
réputation
[Applaudissements]
avec en prime c'est que oui c'est aussi
ça la promo chardon de niji son avance
se félicite formidable spectacle
et ça vous restera stable
c'est un truc qui va avoir conçu un peu
comme rabbi jacob j'espère j'accueille
maintenant mano solo
[Musique]
un solo bonsoir alors vous avez déclaré
à longueur d'onde
j'aime pas la télé mais j'adore y aller
c'est vrai que je peux pas y passer sans
faire le zapping
parce que finalement la télé fait pour
ne rien dire et moi j'ai toujours
quelque chose à dire voilà donc voilà
j'ai dit ça mais aujourd'hui à badaling
willy 20 minutes entre eibar aujourd'hui
ce que vous avez à dire mano solo c'est
que vous sortez indices votre huitième
album depuis 1993
ça s'appelle les animals alors au départ
la moitié des morceaux étaient destinés
à juliette gréco
mais la ferme ne s'est pas fait et c'est
vous qui les chantent et c'est vrai
voilà alors gréco vous dit quand on vous
dit qu'il ya du sexe et de la sueur dans
votre dans votre album écho kae qui
voulait ça voilà c'est gréco qui qui
trouvait un peu millions ce qu'on lui
avait fait jusque jusque là où elles en
étaient rendus dans sa production
elle a du bon maintien wef et mois du
sang du sexe et de la sueur rappelons
qu'intel a même juliette qui dominait
sacha distel way absolument absolument
on s'est rendu compte ce soir faut vous
le dire quand même que sacha distel en
fait étaient dominés nous on le prenait
pour un un playboy voir giegold passe un
peu pas du tout en fait que ça soit
juliette gréco jeanne moreau ou brigitte
bardot elle le dominer et elles ont
planté et il était très malheureux en
fait sacha distel et est un sentimental
voilà ce qu'on a appris ce soir
malheureux malheureux avec les femmes
sacha distel ma chanteur malheureux
comme un chanteur malheureux voilà alors
à part ça votre album est un album assez
apaisés a voulu relais moins qu'avant
non bah c'est parce que c'était pour
juliette
voilà bah ouais c'est des chansons qui
sont dans une tonalité que j'avais fait
pour elle quand même bien travaillé
quand même pour sa grosse voix chaude 1
n'est pas vraiment la mienne
donc là je suis obligé de chanter comme
j'ai pas dit ça me fait du bien puisque
marc de gueuler parce que j'en ai marre
de ne pas écouter mes disques en fait
parce qu'il soit le motif
mais il ya aussi une chose c'est
peut-être que vous êtes devenu plus
sociable en français sur dix ans à
présent bien sûr évidemment il faut être
con quand même content que d un bon
retour quoi nous reste est aigri il faut
avoir moins de cons c'est quoi qui vous
a appris à vivre la réussite
enfin deux le contact avec les gens de
la reconnaissance que le public oui
quoique la salle soit pleine en fait
c'est ça qui est important le disent
qu'ils sont là pour ça ce qui est
important c'est que pendant deux heures
vraiment je m'éclate comme un ouais
comme un gamin corps communs pleine
liberté penser à ça c'est précieux il ya
un morceau qui s'appelle savane où vous
dites je n'ai plus ce sentiment si
violente si méchant non c'est vrai qu'au
début je monte sur scène j'en avais
absolument rien à [ __ ] de ce qu'on
pouvait penser de moi quoi c'était
j'avais juste une envie c'était de
mettre mes chansons dans la gueule des
gens en vérité c'était un peu
effectivement en cours de route
mon plaisir de monter sur scène il a
complètement évolué là c'est moi j'ai un
plaisir de monter sur scène parce que je
me fendre la gueule avec des gens qui
attendent que ça de moi c'est
complètement différent
j'ai plus du tout envie de leur faire du
mal alors il ya un morceau vous êtes à
quai à la trinité travail famille
sarkozy
ouais ça vous inquiète sarkozy vous
pensez que quand même j'ai pas j'arrête
pas de penser à tous ces gens avant les
élections critique qui était persuadé
que la droite et la gauche c'était la
même chose
depuis quand même quelques temps que
franchement c'est pas la même chose
quand on voit des gens qui déboule au
pouvoir et qui c'est qui s'attaque à qui
oji temps ils ont stigmatisé les gitans
et avait même eu des députés pour lire
oui on se demande bien comment ils se
payent leur bagnole je trouve qu'ils ont
fait que ça à quoi d'essayer de
retrouver des têtes de turc
comment ils ont fait avec des
intermittents aussi c'est à dire que
nous les intermittents en génère de
l'emploi bien plus con et parasites
comment comme ses dires a voulu le faire
croire sous s'aggrave quand même qu'on
ait un sarkozy à l'économie et puis un
sarkozy au medef ça fait quand même
c'est le frère de sabon je suis pas moi
un type en gaz est simplement un quand
on a la chance que moi d'être un artiste
de rien [ __ ] de ces journées on peut
pas ne pas assister à ça et avoir envie
de le dire d'une manière ou d'une autre
qu'il serait peut-être temps que que
bacon qu'on se réveille qu'on arrête de
moutonné quoi ces noms c'est encore une
fois une chanson à mi figue mi raisin
parce que je dis que je me fais mon
petit grand soir puis c'est ridicule pas
sur un seul à délirer sur ma chanson
avec laquelle j'ai vu mon temps mais
quand j'étais gamin quoi le chant des
partisans
c'est un peu pathétique d'ailleurs la
chanson s'appelle du vent
[Musique]
dix ans
alors vous n'êtes pas très nouvelle
chanson française avoue benjamin biolay
et bénabar yann tiersen c'est pas trop
votre on les entend pas si tu veux c'est
le mec il se susurre pour les vieilles
sur la page d histoire de complètement
consensuel qui mange pas de pain des
petites historiettes je sais pas moi je
j'entends même pas j'écoute même pas toi
c'est plutôt quoi elle était très de
ouais c'est ça c'est les têtes j'aime
bien c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
parce qu'il ya autre chose que des
chansons niaises co cc c'est tout un
univers culturel cliquez sur scène quoi
c mano solo libération de 24 septembre
chroniques et les animals sous la plume
de ludovic perrin en dix ans mano solo a
tellement annoncé sa mort que sa survie
a aujourd'hui quelque chose de banal
réchappé in extremis à grâce à la
trithérapie
le chanteur du sida a progressivement
ouvert son propos au monde construction
mais elle cessera milliers manque de
place pour ça je me mens étoiles comme
ça tout le monde est content finalement
s est ce que on peut pas vivre dans ce
pays en ayant dit une fois dans ta vie
que tu était atteint d'une maladie sans
contre la ressorte à chaque fois que tu
gères tu sors quelques peurs fut
effectivement moi je suis éclaboussé
partout où je passe quoi j'en ai un peu
plein de cucquois maintenant je vais
peut-être réagir à la limite qui tout le
monde va croire que tiens ça y est ton
nom plus toi aussi
c'est en fait ce qui est mano solo ce
qui m'énerve c'est que tu n'en parlait
plus et d'un seul coup libération plutôt
des gens qui s'entendent ils s'étaient
parlé pour moi parce que j'ai dit un
jour ouais et alors ouais twitter il est
là depuis dix ans poursuit
j'en ai plein cur dire que plutôt que de
dire que ton disent que leur plaisait
pas il a fallu que qu'on introduise
l'article par le fait que
moi je suis sentir dès 6h je sais pas
vous a vu ça ce type mais cette
séparation
si tu veux il est 0 à l'aller perrin
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de lui s'il est
pour moi et c'est l'exemple type de
toute la presse entière depuis dix ans
qui me poursuit finalement je suis une
démonstration permanente que il règne
dans ce pays
une exclusion positive si tu veux par
exemple j'étais le titre de mon article
de mon droit de réponse dans libération
aujourd'hui ils l'ont passée les
endroits de réponse en enlevant tout ce
qu'ils ont merdé bien sujet et ils ont
rajouté le sida dans le titre moi m'ont
dit qu'ils s'étaient d'exclusion positif
le titre est devenu un sida comme
exclusion positif ça veut plus rien dire
parce que c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est
comme le berceau de ramener le cid est
exactement l fois tout le monde le sache
quoi si ça donc sachez le voilà j'ai
trouvé un truc je moi je met mon étoile
quoi comme juif
sachez le quoi ok que tout le monde est
sage quoi ça bien foutu l'ambiance non
mais c'est vrai que tout le monde le
sache
lorsque tu dis toi c'est que tu es
artiste avant de décider avec chaque
fois entre sort sac voilà libéré
exactement c'est comme s'ils tombaient
par exemple je fais des chansons pour
juliette gréco
je je je lis dans une dépêche de
l'agencé de presse que animaux dans une
chanson qui s'appelle je n'y peux rien
je parle de ma séropositivité toi jeu
mais c'est n'importe quoi ça devient
c'est de toute façon une information
qu'il est indispensable de donner dès
qu'on parle de mano solo
donc moi je commence à en avoir plein
que j'ai cru que cette démonstration
était flagrante et qu'elle finirait par
être comprise de tous mais finalement
non elle n'est pas flagrante c'est pour
ça que je peux menti cinéma aujourd'hui
c'est parce que j'en ai plein qu
aujourd'hui parce que ça commence à bien
faire moi je vis et finalement ce qui
est paradoxal finalement c'est que quand
ils m'ont cru le porte drapeau d'une
maladie j'étais pas malade
aujourd'hui je suis malade j'ai vraiment
autre chose à penser autre chose à
raconter
rosa et mais dans la vie et pas me
chercher et leurs conneries moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on me lâche la grappe
en fait quand à parler dans ton premier
album en 81
ça fait quand même longtemps tu disais
j'ai la mort aux trousses qui me fout
les x et en 95 qui en a parlé d' une
deuxième fois sur la scène du bataclan
en disant cette phrase fameuse de
nouvelles une bonne et une mauvaise
la bonne c'est qu'il plus séropositif
est-ce que j'ai le sida
si tu veux manger droit d'en parler
ouais j'ai aussi le droit d'être
tranquille mais j'ai le droit de ne pas
être montrés du doigt j'ai le droit de
pas sa figure pas sur mon front sur la
carte d'identité tu vois je suis le
droit j'ai le droit de deux qu'on fasse
attention à ce que à mes chansons bordel
de merde tu vois qu'une critique le type
il a trouvé que mon album n'était pas
terrible il a quel dire je n'en ai rien
à [ __ ] tout va mais pourquoi il a
besoin de dire que c'est vachement moins
bien mais c'est lorsqu'il désactiver tu
va mieux
voilà c'est ça donc c'est plus c'est
simple les monuments fait s'affairent
encore penser aux gens que grâce aux
trithérapies on ne meurt pas du sida
c'est ce qui est une connerie
monumentale mais alors aujourd'hui alors
que les charlatans et des capotes parce
qu'ils s'imaginent qu'on se rassure
comme avec 3 aspirine tu vois c'est à
tous les niveaux c'est nous importe
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi et par
exemple il ya aussi c'est intéressant
quand on voit que dans mon droit de
réponse je parlais d'un article moi
j'avais parlé effectivement d'ici
d'appontement les ponts de [ __ ] la
paix et que si on voulait parler à
senlis avec toi là c'est pour une
pulsion voulez parler de 6 à condat y
voir les docteur tu vois que quelque
chose à raconter
mais moi j'ai rien à dire tout va et
cité un article que j'avais cité dans
mon droit de réponse pour dire ça ils
ont enlevé ce bout d'un coup je parle de
ça et perrin refait un droit de réponse
en dessous en disant toi dans cet
article on a parlé c'est carrément une
manipulation mais c'est démentiel tu
vois c'est à dire il faut absolument en
plus qui c'est le dernier mot tu vois
c'est quelque chose de chez pas pour moi
c'est du lepénisme ça va pas chercher
plus loin quoi c'est stigmatiser en
permanence un individu moi je ne
supporte pas parce que je pense que j'ai
quand même autre chose à vendre que sept
collégiens qui s'est blessé depuis dix
ans je raconte autre chose les gens
sinon il y aurait pas me voir
franchement il faudrait de cons pour
acheter le disque d'un mec il parle de
sida depuis dix ans en plus ils crèvent
pas alors qu'il se met à réfléchir quoi
toi c'est ne pas crever quoi toi si je
devenais james dean mais c'est bien fait
les choses au point là ouais j'en
profite d'être la fille
il regarde les mecs
alors mano solo on va on va revenir un
artiste on va revenir on va revenir à
l'artiste on va revenir aux poètes avec
une interview en un mot
[Musique]
kevin au mot qui sonne le mieux dans la
langue française pour toi pontault
combault
quel est le mot que tu préfères entendre
en anglais fuck you quel est le mot que
tu n'as jamais dit à une femme
fuck you quels mots que tu n'as jamais
dit un homme
cette nuit le mot que tu ne voudrais pas
entendre dans la bouche d'un enfant
sécurité de l'emploi quel est le mot qui
pourrait te faire tout quitter pareil
quel est le mot qui revient le plus
souvent dans tes chansons
la vie quel est le mot qui revient le
plus souvent dans ta tête
les sentiments
quel est le mot qui revient le plus
souvent quand on parle de toi
talent quel est le mot qui te rappelle
ton meilleur souvenir premier olympia ça
c'était bien
quel est le mot qui résume t faiblesse
dans la vie les chiites
quels mots qui donnent envie de gagner
tu as tout perdu quels mots qui donnent
envie de pleurer
ludovic perrin
j'ai pitié pour lui quel est le mot que
tu voudrais qu'on graves sur la pierre
tombale ni de la révolution s'appelle
les amis
là
[Musique]
derrière je vous laisser filer au revoir
j'ai vu saint-hernin belgique une
gonzesse ciudad real ou rien à bientôt
merci
et maintenant
[Musique]
j'accueille jacques vergès
non
jacques vergès bonsoir bonsoir ça va
très bien alors vous êtes l'avocat du
diable le défendeur des causes
indéfendables le fln à l'époque klaus
barbie
georges ibrahim abdallah omar haddad
carlos le préfet bonnet qui s'est
rétractée quand même vous avez vu cette
semaine
oui j'ai vu un c'est son droit
ouais elle est pas vous défendiez
complètement le contraire il a dit le
dirigeant l époque je le croyais alors
vous avez aussi défendu milsé vie que
vous défendez tariqa 6 il y en a car
vous êtes s'est piqué le business c'est
salam hussein
non je sais rien parce que j'ai vu qu'il
ya un dénommé ludo qui dit qu'il est
l'avocat de salem vous savez un type qui
est au secret sa famille
ils partent ils savent pas famille
désignant avocats une autre partie
désigne un autre 1 pour l'instant pays
n'a désigné personne une partie de sa
famille m'a désigné une partie de sa
famille a dit d'ailleurs le confrère que
vous dit emmanuel ludot
voilà qantas et pas vous vous le
défendriez comment bertrand cantat à
vous écouter vous avez un drame qui
ressemble à celui de qantas à ce
shakespeare l'a écrit là-dessus c'est
othello 1 et à l'époque on n'a pas fait
ça une histoire de femme battue on a
fait ça une histoire une tragédie alors
est-ce que vous pouvez défendre maître
collard je pensais à ça à imaginer qu'un
jour on le met en prison oui ce vécu des
mois je suis prêt à défendre tout le
monde à condition que le titre soit
d'accord avec moi sur le système de
défense maître collard comme ben oui
s'il est d'accord avec moi sur le
système des français veut bien se
prendre le chou
connaître sérieux adolf hitler ils ont
bien défendu un journaliste américain me
posais cette question et je lui ai
répondu mais même bouche je le défendrai
c'est pas pareil au niveau de la vanne
ses moyens déjà je mets deux
ouais vous avez défendu à la barre ou
pas staline mao paul potts barbie carlos
minos et vic et maintenant vous en
prenez à bouche
dans un livre qui s'appelle la
démocratie à visage obscène le vrai
catéchisme de george bush
publié aux éditions de la table ronde
alors c'est un plaidoyer anti bush c'est
à dire que l'avocat devient cette fois
procureur vous dit busch évidemment à
inventer un ennemi qui n'existe pas les
responsables du 11-septembre sont
partout sauf en irak et il a plongé le
monde dans une nouvelle guerre de cent
ans alors il ya là dessus tout le monde
est à peu près d'accord mais il ya un
truc quand même quand vous dites
les responsables du 11-septembre sont
partout sauf en irak vous ajoutez est
sans doute plus près de la maison
blanche que de l'afghanistan vous
sous-entendez quoi la boussole vous
entendez que le 11 septembre pourrait
être une manipulation une invention je
dis simplement que les types qui ont
fait le 11 septembre
séjourner aux états unis depuis au moins
deux ans ouais qui se sont entraînés à
piloter qui était en rapports entre eux
qui menaient une vie qu'il n'était pas
tout à fait celle de tout le monde et
que les services américaines n'ont rien
vu ou n'ont rien voulu voir c'est tout
ce que je disais sur le rien voulu voir
que je vous intéresse oui vous pensez
que c'est voulu que c'est la négligence
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
alors là je ne voudrais pas porter des
accusations
il touche le monde a droit à la
présomption d'innocence
je ne voudrais pas dans l'ignorance des
événements porter une accusation qui ne
serait pas fondée
mais je dis que toutes les hypothèses
sont possibles si ce qui est assez juste
grandi dans l'ignorance des événements
ça c'est bien faire un bouquin
de quelqu'un qui dise je suis dans
l'ignorance de ce dont je parle c'est
intéressant c'est une bonne idée de
wendy ça c'est non mais c'est lucide
c'est intéressant parce que c'est très
lucide devant le danger si ça l'était au
site d exemple je fais des analyses
on va voir on y arrive on y arrive
chopin
non mais ça m'avait choqué c'était
justement un départ en parlant du
système américain c'était il ya eu un
blizzard qui a été donné à un des
pirates qu'ils étaient dans l'avion un
des terroristes qui étaient morts donc
dans l'avion a reçu son visa six mois
après ouais donc alors qu'il connaissait
son nom il savait qu'il était ça il a
reçu un visa
je l'avais glee jans la question que je
posais c'est de savoir si c'est de la
négligence ça peut arriver
ou si c'est volontaire à l'ès 1 est-ce
qu'on a laissé faire le problème dans ce
genre d'affaires se ne jamais dans
l'immédiat qu'on a lavé réponse il faut
attendre combien de temps m parce que
nous il faut qu'on aille bien
dans ce domaine il faut apprendre la
patience alors pour vous mettre vergès
non seulement george bush a déjà perdu
la guerre mais en plus dit vous et c'est
le titre de votre livre
il a donné à la démocratie un visage
obscène alors effectivement vous dites
les soldats us ne se cache plus pour
torturer comme c'était le cas par
exemple en la guerre d'algérie il c'est
vrai que les gens torturés médical chez
huit là ils font des photos ils font des
vidéos et tout le monde les voit à quoi
c'est ce que je dis ils vont ici il ya
des photos souvenirs
on fouille le sac d'une jeune femme on
trouve dedans une photo d'elle au milieu
des palmiers sur un chameau et puis une
photo d'elle tirant par une laisse un
homme qui était moribond ouais c'est ça
qui publie est nouveau et c'est ça on
torturait beaucoup je crois sous saddam
hussein peut-être davantage qu'en
amérique et il me semble que d'habitude
vous défendez des causes moins
démagogique beaucoup moins courageux que
d'habitude d'habitude vous êtes ce
courageux attaqué monsieur bush vous
pensez que c'est un banal c'est banal et
démago ouais ouais bon point de vue
mérite l'original en 10 ans l' inverse
je crois même le faisant vous défendez
en faisant commune tout comme quelqu'un
et qu'on vous dit mais il ya un type qui
est finie c'est la manière de dire
laisser ce type tranquille en ce moment
vous faites la voix cet argument
classique pour défendre bouche si vous
êtes pour jacques tapez 1 tapez 2 on va
laisser passer une page de gauche ont
tous dit après ça vous dit quand les
américains torturant miracle quand ils
font des photos il lé monde voilà c'est
dit pas ça seulement jeudi par exemple
que monsieur russe fait intervient il a
un rapport d'un gardien qui dit on a
forcé ce type va rester debout
4 heures et il ajoute de sa main
pourquoi pas 8 pourquoi ta douce
donc c'est le pouvoir au plus haut
sommet qui se mêlent des détails de la
torture et je trouve que ça qui est
effrayant il ya introduit en plus dans
la torture qui c'est qui ce fait là nous
n'avons pas seulement la torture qu'on a
dénoncé à propos de la guerre d'algérie
mais nous avons la volonté d'avilir en
plus non pas seulement de faire souffrir
mais d'avilir quand voûte
photographié des hommes nus que vous
contraignez à des gestes obscènes
manifestement vous voulez les avis lire
surtout dans un très long mais quelque
chose
ce qui est surtout dans un pays c'est
que ces photos ont été publiées en
amérique très tôt et très vite ça prouve
justement que la démocratie fonctionne
là bas et qu'on montre et que la presse
est libre c'est beaucoup plus le cas
qu'à propos de l'algérie où les où la
torture n'a été dénoncé que beaucoup
plus tard dans notre pays nous sommes
ici en france alors là je sais ce procès
qui est fait c'est vrai alors utiliser
le fait que l'amérique est libre pour
répondre et à ceux ci c'est que en
france monsieur aussaresses se cacher là
bas on se montre c'est déjà une
différence je dis aussi que le général
miers devant fallouja dit c'est un nid à
ras que je vais détruire un le général
de gaulle proposé aux insurgés algériens
la paix des braves
jeudi il ya là deux attitudes
différentes
et là dessus on peut être pour avoir de
la sympathie pour monsieur bush mais il
faut le constater il ya instruction en
parlant de falloudja laisse un peu
énorme dit qu on les torture en
diffusant avec des haut-parleurs géant
des morceaux décide ici
ce poids se blesser pour éteindre
morceau d'aile d'un autre ce soit
d'autre des décibels monstrueux
oui non mais c'est dit sinon l'écoutent
tous les jours c'est pas mais pas mais
pas diffuser avec intel autant de
décibels en revanche à vous parler des
viols et là vous vous appuyez sur les
révélations de seymour hersh du new
yorker et vous dites l'armée américaine
compte dans ses rangs un corps de
spécialistes inconnu des autres armées
des sodomies sts oui car c'est pas des
saddamistes a cédé sa demie c'est ça il
ya une formation
celle que tu as fait ta fille de [ __ ]
dure non mais d'après d'après seymour
hersh le pentagone possède des photos
d'enfants irakiens se montrer qu'il ne
commenterait c'est ce que monsieur
rossfeld à 10,7 chesnais devant le
parlement américain douala devant le
sénat en disant il ya des photos qui
sent tellement horrible qu'on n'ose pas
vous les montrer alors vous dites c'est
un drôle de visage un visage obscène que
bush donnent de la démocratie dans un
pays où le système bicaméral c'est un
système à deux assemblées existait trois
mille ans avant jésus-christ ce qui
explique dites-vous cette volonté
d'éradiquer l'histoire et la mémoire de
l'irak jeudi que lorsque les troupes
d'occupation sont entrés dans bagdad
ils ont protégé le ministère du pétrole
mais ils ont laissé piller le musée
archéologique et au musée archéologique
les pièces des copies n'ont pas été
volés seuls les aurait laissés pièces
originales ont été volés de sorte qu'il
ya là un pipe un pillage qui était
organisé est ce que j'ajoute c'est les
débats juridiques qui ont eu lieu en
angleterre et aux états unis pour que
les lois qui répriment le recel d'objets
d'art volées ne soit plus en application
malraux faisait pareil et découpez des
bas-reliefs elle était encore oui mais
alors là le problème c'est toujours
pareil quand vous condamner un acte qui
est actuel on vous dit mais monsieur
malraux à fait autre chose
malraux est mort alors c'est facile
d'accabler malraux aujourd'hui encore
quel jour
oui alors vous parlez de koula que vous
dites dans la vieille europe les prisons
étaient au coeur des villes dans les
dictatures elles sont aux confins de
l'empiré c'est à dire auschwitz en
pologne
la kolyma en sibérie et vous dit bush
lui finalement ils créent des camps qui
sont un pas aux confins de l'empiré sont
l'autre côté du monde
diab guantanamo et les îles chagos
qu'ils sont des êtres sud de l'inde en
plein afghanistan ils viendront près où
est donc la ses blagues goulag rila
lorsque vous comparez ça au goulag
comparer ça au camp nazi et vos goulag a
été employée par les américains ouais
les problèmes et je crois que c'est
l'honneur des américains de dénoncer
cela mais ce n'est pas parce que les
américains dénoncent là que nous
n'allons pas le dénoncer vous dites si
la communauté internationale
gypa la situation deviendra comme à
l'époque hitlérienne munich aboutissant
à auschwitz et vous voyez bush
allant plus loin devenir un deuxième ce
que vous savez que les guerres qu'ils
préparent ce moment si jamais ils
repassent et nous avons très bien
commencé lac ce qu'on a appelé la kz ni
mal parce que ça prend l'aspect d'une
croisade
on met la morale et la religion à des
intérêts purement terrestre
quand vous voyez par exemple les allées
critique déjà émises contre l'iran ne
sais pas du tout ce qui va passer deux
avec l'iran demain et donc manifestement
nous allons vers une situation où le
chaos sera créé dans toute une partie du
monde et ceci est très inquiétant je
comprends pas je
ce qui est inquiétant c'est vous je
crois merci parce que oui c'est
peut-être un compliment mais on ne peut
pas mélanger tout je crois pas qu'on
puisse mélanger hitler george bush ou
nous la voulons dire je prends des
années
mais l'histoire vous avez un homme là il
ya par exemple meunier trop faci me lis
qu'on a accepté on accepter munich est
au bout de munich a eu la guerre il ya
eu une guerre il a eu encore et je dis
si on laisse un pays des dirigeants d'un
pays peul payant tiébélé ses dirigeants
atteint de vertiges de puissance faire
ce qu'ils veulent
parce que par exemple à guantanamo on
n'applique pas les lois de la guerre le
ya une cour pénale internationale qui a
été créé la plupart beaucoup de pays
l'europe à accepter que la compétence et
les états unis refusent cette compétence
donc nous avons un pays qui se place au
dessus des autres et dire cela ce n'est
pas polémiquer c'est se référer aux
documents américains eux mais je suis en
accord avec vous sur le fait qu' il ne
faut pas mélanger la religion et la
politique
il faut pas instrumentaliser l'idée du
bien pour faire n'importe quoi et je
suis pas quelqu'un qui est partisan de
george bush mais je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire que la démocratie a un
visage obscène brise à ce qu ces trois
mois la cia dans les prisons assez
positif de dollars rien vouloir visage
au bessat et moi d'essayer de m'exprimer
je vous ai laissé la parole oui je sais
le principe de la démocratie que vous
trouvé obscène c'est de laisser les gens
parlaient vous savez c'est ce système là
où tout le monde même quand on n'est pas
d'accord on peut parler jusqu'au bout de
sa phrase
donc je crois que pour vouloir propager
la démocratie c'est une bonne nouvelle
vouloir remplacer un tyran par un vote
ce qui est en train d'avoir lieu où
bientôt d'avoir lieu en irak
c'est une bonne nouvelle en tout cas ça
a lieu en afghanistan ça a lieu
peut-être mal mais ça a lieu les femmes
ne pouvaient pas sortir dans la rue en
afghanistan maintenant elles vont voter
c'est différent quand même lorsque vous
me permettez de parler maintenant
d'après la production d'opium en
afghanistan était multipliée par dix
certes il est toujours le truc qui
cloche
olemps voir mais quand vous parlez de
l'alizé partie rétablis
vous dit la production d'opium a été
musicien est passé au riz du complot ne
s'est pas la théorie du complot c'est la
ville de fait c'est la vraie septembre a
été organisée par george bush en vous et
couvrez sonné en ce moment comme
certaines personnes résonné pendant la
guerre d'algérie
voilà on leur disait aux tortures il dit
oui mais vous avez en face de vous des
fellaghas qui sont horribles
vient alors la mer était très négatif on
va essayer d'être positif on va faire
une interview bon côté alors comme on
connaît déjà la lar mauvais côté on va
essayer de trouver le bon côté si vous
deviez dire quelque chose de bien sur
klaus barbie vous diriez quoi par
exemple
vous savez quand je défends barbie je ne
défends pas que quelqu'un forcément de
bien je défends quelqu'un et j'essaie de
comprendre comment il est arrivé à faire
ce qu'il a fait parce que un procès pour
être pédagogique pour être exemplaire
doit examiner tous les aspects d'une
réalité non pas pour excuser mais pour
comprendre si au contraire on ne regarde
pas tout à ce moment là on s'expose ne
pas comprendre et le procès perd sa
valeur pédagogique
si on dit de lui que c'est un monstre on
a éliminé tout débat se mons ne nous
ressemblent tandis que si on dit c'est
un être humain qui est arrivé à faire
cela on se pose des questions sur nous
mêmes et comment empêcher que ces choses
ne se reproduisent
et si vous deviez dire quelque chose de
bien sur 1000 cv que vous diriez quoi
bon coup droit je dirais qu'il se défend
pas mal
bon coup droit je comprends qu'un joueur
de tennis entre si vous deviez dire
quelque chose de bien sur saddam hussein
vous diriez quoi je dirais que la guerre
qu'on lui a faite le poste dans une
position la plus confortable possible si
vous deviez dire quelque chose de bien
sûr bernard bonnet vous diriez quoi ça
m'est difficile et les différentes
versions que bernard bonnet a donné de
ce qu'il a fait d'où l'expression de
gérard bonnet blanc si vous deviez dire
quelque chose de positif sur papon vous
diriez quoi je vous dirais que je ne
peux pas par dire quelque chose de
positif pas pompeux des raisons peuvent
parfaitement personnel je défends des
vous le rappeliez les militants du fln
pendant la guerre et papon été préfet de
police à paris et les l'auteur et de des
ratonnades du 17 octobre
donc là dessus je n'ai pas une sympathie
particulière pour lui et donc je ne peux
pas vous parler de lui et de manière
absolument modéré
jr je vais bien merci
jones m
non
jacques vergès merci d'avoir été avec
nous mais je vous en prie à bientôt au
revoir
[Musique]
à
et maintenant
au temps
en bref chez herbert léonard
[Applaudissements]
herbert léonard
les preneurs
j'adore cette chanson c'est vraiment une
chance julien lepers une chance 5 julien
lepers pour la musique
evelyne buggy pour les paroles tu es la
production c'est le chant voilà un verre
léonard pour le champ alors dans le
nouvel album d'herbert léonard
il ya la version groupe 2004 2 pour le
plaisir et c'est pas mal
j'entends
um
mais
[Musique]
l'un est celui qui
tous
il ya ça aussi à je tombe mais
ça
en rond
non
aussi haut
m
où
cela
ok
j c
herbert léonard je tombe extrait de
ventre charme et beauté voilà herbert
léonard qu'on a appelé le barry white
français comme toi je la vois un peu
moins graves comme un non mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya des trucs quand il ya des
choses très barry white
j'écoutais l'intro de musique érotique
on dirait vraiment de la musique de film
porno
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais vous lire l'écran parce
que on fait pas toujours gaffe aux
personnes qui écoutent bien sentir ta
bouche effronté c'est un début épouse et
tous mes rêves dans un délicieux va et
vient et doucement décalotter fini fini
bien y en a une aussi
je n'ai qu'un pays celui de ton corps je
n'ai qu'un péché ton triangle d'or
franchement est-ce que c'est pas beau ça
bravo herbert
[Musique]
avec des
en appréciant les deux sur m6 le
dimanche soir
c'est xxeme ça ouais xxl pense que les
1150 sur nous
je tiens à le préciser l'effort en
stations font les adresser un mini buggy
parce que c'est elle qui a écrit les
textes
ils sont bien les textes et ça c'est qui
qu'a fait sa j'adore
ce sens
asetek site pap non sérieux ça ne fait
que c'est pas toi beauregard qu'est-ce
qui fait que ça cesse toujours discret
charge et c'était quoi le triangle d'or
j'ai pas vu de la forme
je crois qu'il faut refaire son
éducation sexuelle à la ronde et le
magic j'ai compris mais là je suis
largué ça peut arriver parfois alors
herbert léonard êtes né en binôme soir
déjà bonsoir bonsoir et un bel honneur
vous êtes né en 1945 à à strasbourg
votre vrai nom c'est leonhardt vous
voulez que je vous dise vraiment herbert
von d art
lenhardt voilà oui c'est très cher mr
lenhardt alors 20 ans après votre
naissance après le service militaire
vous faites partie d'un groupe qui
s'appelle les jets et puis lé lionceaux
est ce que tu te souviens des lionceaux
les lions s'étaient des beatles
française avait des doubles comme ça
absolument il faisait que des reprises
des beatles absolument français en
france et en français précise on le
précise enlevée c'était vachement bien
et je ne savais pas et que vous aviez
fait partie des lionceaux j'ai fait
partie des lionceaux sur la fin parce
qu'ils sont passés un jour par
strasbourg et puis m'ont vu sur scène et
comme je cherchais un guitariste 110,15
celui-là il ya du matériel super va
l'emmener avec nous et alors le le 3
janvier 66 herbert léonard fait la
première partie du chuck berry à
l'époque et vernis bird
tu te souviens de ronnie bird c'était
avec la frange et où vous savez ce qu'il
est devenu pas vous laisser dire ça à
maître vergès
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire des
choses pareilles vous savez je l'avais
pas fait la tournée que j'ai fait c'est
ce qui est de venir libérer je crois
qu'elle a travaillé pour france 2 à un
moment donné il est à new york y revint
les appartements c'est incroyable ouais
je sais pas en fait je ne sais pas très
bien mais ce que ce dont je me souviens
c'est que dans cette tournée là il y
avait donc nous ce qu'on appelait les la
vedette anglaise
il y avait ronnie bird en vedette
américaine et c'était axe absolument à
mourir de plaisir
et puis avec chuck berry qui venaient
faire son boulot hein parce qu'il n'est
vraiment faire son boulot c'est tout
ouais alors en 68 gros succès avec une
reprise de jane pitt nec qu'on retrouve
air sur votre nouvel album en duo avec
karine lopez que gagner entrée des
artistes organisée par pascal sevran sur
france 2 parce qu'elles sauront que nous
recevrons la semaine prochaine et on 70
le 12ème round 70 c'est l'accident vous
raté un virage et vous retrouvé encastré
mme sousa comme vous vous êtes défiguré
a été défigurée au mg ressembler à
frankenstein pendant un an à peu près je
n'avais pas très envie de me regarder
dans une glace et je sortais plus quoi
je crois très et je me suis dit qu'à ce
moment là que le petit bout de carrière
j'ai eu bas il était terminée quoi c'est
fini oui c'est quand vous êtes revenu un
an après il ya des mecs qui étaient
arrivés sur le marché vous aviez plus
votre votre place ça allait très vite à
l'époque on faisait un disent tous les
trois mois 1 parce que ça durerait pas
plus longtemps et puis de s'absenter un
an comme ça sans rien faire vous oubliez
tout de suite on va en tout cas le
métier sérieusement herbert léonard si
vous n'aviez pas eu cet accident
vous aurez une meilleure carrière vous
pensez j'en sais rien en tout cas ça m'a
été profitable vous a freiné dans votre
carrière
ça c'est sûr j'aurais peut-être mieux
fait de freiner à mon doigt relieurs
alors à ce moment là vous avez quand
même après votre accident une
vous êtes dépressif ce qui est assez
compréhensible et vous vous en sortez
grâce à votre à votre femme
oui cléo et votre fille et les ah oui
parce que on a fait un enfant à ce
moment là la cassette
et puis ça m'a enfin ça a été un
enchaînement de de tout quoi
ma femme qui me soutenaient parce que je
me tapais la tête contre les murs
sa pensée avec les années c'est bon je
sais que c'est pas bon mais quand même
ouais si votre femme peu de femmes
travaillaient à l'autre bout de la
france donc vous oui c'est vous qui vous
occupez de l'argent puisque je pouvais
plus rien et vous vous occupiez de votre
fille oui et c'est ça finalement qui
vous a donc il nous a redonné le goût de
vivre
oui c était quoi le pire moment de cette
année là haut je crois que le pire
moment c'est de me voir dans la glace
scalper 1 avec des points de suture
parce que j'ai il faut dire que j'ai
fini dans une clinique une maternité en
fait non qu'on marque uzi avec des fils
de toutes les couleurs et très très
grossièrement donc j'en garde encore
qu'elle a trop pas trop ça s'est arrangé
avec le temps mais jusqu'à quand même
une cicatrice ici mais les gosses
adorent ça et je sais et et je crois que
le pire moment c'était justement de
quand je suis sorti dessous le camion
parce que j'étais encore conscient et de
voir dans la première glace que j'avais
en face de moi
en faisant ça et tout d'un coup en
voyant tous mes cheveux dans la main ça
c'était terrible
le succès reviendra en 1981 avec pour le
plaisir effectivement et en attendant
pendant les années 70 vous commencé à
écrire pour aviation magazine et vous
devenez le spécialiste mondial de
l'aviation militaire russe c'est à dire
kerber léonard c'est insensé
j'ai fait cinq bouquins le premier
faisait 500 pages il peser deux kilos et
demi qui peut l'accepter sur les cds sur
les chasseurs vous avez écrit
effectivement sur les tubes paul f
les iliouchine ont des sukhoï et
aujourd'hui vous publiez un livre sur
les chasseurs polikarpov chez la rivière
mais c'est insensé ça c'est à dire que
quand on voit pas quand on retrouve
alcoa s'intéresse zizou mme mon garçon
là si tu veux d'un coup c'est quand même
assez assez grave si c'est devenu chez
vous pratiquement une perversion dans
l'aviation militaire religions antiques
remet musique érotique sur l'action
[Musique]
frédéric beigbeder qu'il prouve qu'il
pourrait être un grand producteur de
télévision là tu viens de le prouver
frédéric non mais c'est insensé si une
perversion chez vous non pour moi moi
j'appellerai ça une passion couet gérer
les avions militaires russes et pas
première moitié du 20e siècle est en
plus et de couleur gris métal non mais
j'ai découvert tout bêtement un jour
chez dans un couloir d'aviation magazine
où il y avait des milliers de photos qui
n'était pas classé une photo d'un petit
avion russe qui s'appelait le i 207 et
j'ai voulu savoir comment ce commet un
truc comme ça pouvait voler et j'essaie
d'en savoir plus j'ai pas trouvé
alors je me suis dit plutôt que d'écrire
comme les autres sur les français les
anglais les allemands lui par at c les
allemands tout le monde veut tout savoir
sur ce soit mais c'est exactement ça
fascine beaucoup je me suis dit bas
puisque personne écrit sur les russes
je vais me spécialiser alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont les les policarpo à fond dit
c'est le roi du chasseur mais pourquoi
ses droits et sa presse et droit des
chasseurs qui aujourd'hui parce que
souvenez vous au coeur c'est l'avion du
public et le personnel enseignant du
poulpe et culpa un polikarpov le pool
cassation ici qu'est ce qu'ils ont de
plus car maria une guerre de 1936 à 1939
qui s'appelait la guerre d'espagne
ouais et pendant la guerre d'espagne
sont apparus deux types de chasseurs
russes
le i 15 et le i 16 essais les deux
meilleurs chasseurs du monde à l'époque
et il était russe restera parle de cul
pour que les gens reviennent
je te le dis pour toi c'est pour les
chiffres de dire non mais toute façon
c'est pas avec les chasseurs russes que
vous allez revenir au top herbert on va
voir comment vous pourriez revenir au
top
on va faire une interwiew back to top
[Musique]
alors herbert léonard est ce que pour
revenir au top
vous seriez prêt à vous mettre nue sur
une pochette jamais à vous faire appeler
m6 herbert ça veut dire quoi même si
master of ceremony
why not à faire la première partie d'
elodie d'ekwa d'elodie frégé qui s'est
un peu de respect pour les vrais va tu
sais pas qui c'est est ce que vous
seriez prêt herbert pour revenir au top
a enregistré une version gay de pour le
plaisir
pourtant plaisir j'ai toujours dit que
le jour où je déciderai de d'arrêter de
chanter je sais pas quand ça viendra ni
si ça viendra je ferai une version x2 to
meet you go away
celle là c'est pas la peine
ah j'adore
je crois qu'on va garder je crois que
c'est dessus c'était vraiment un sampler
que je vais garder retirer l'eau chez
vous visitez est ce que vous êtes prêt
pour revenir au top à faire un duo avec
des rappeurs ah oui oui oui j'adore
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à raconter
dans les émissions de télévision vous
êtes tombé dans la drogue
je suis jamais tombé dans la drogue
alors je peux pas dire ça est ce que
vous seriez prêt à faire un lifting dont
je suis prêt à tout sauf à ça d'accord
est ce que vous seriez prêt à dire du
mal de michel drucker jean ne peut pas
non non non il ya un moyen de revenir
d'un couteau a aussi sa branche quand
même s'ils avouent faire naturaliser
québécois non à vous habiller moulant
non plus vous faire photographier dans
voici avec ophélie winter s'est elle me
près de sessa oui vous faire teindre les
cheveux je lui fais j'ai fait deux ans
pendant deux ans j'ai fait notre dame de
paris
ouais j'ai donc me léonard dans une
petite boîte et je vais frollo way et je
me suis fait teindre les cheveux pendant
deux ans au site est horrible mais
j'aime c'est un plaisir extraordinaire à
jouer les méchants est ce que vous
seriez prêt à chanter à la star ac pour
revenir au top
ouais pour revenir au top non un meet up
alors mutoke peut-être est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à prendre gérard louvin en
otage c'est un ami a tenté une vanne
contrebas fait oui il est un ami
donc oui oui oui à soutenir dieudonné je
pense pas non acquitté ce plateau tout
de suite en faisant un énorme scandale
pour revenir au top pour revenir au top
mais je suis beaucoup trop modeste pour
ça non vous auriez près à quoi alors
pour revenir au top
ma productrice a toujours dit que je
manqué d'ambition et je pense qu'elle a
toujours eu raison parce que j'ai jamais
cherché à être constamment au top je ne
sais pas c'est pas seulement l'accident
il ya aussi un manque d'ambition vous
pensez
quelque part oui certainement un jeu
cherche pas écraser tout le monde envie
de ranger une maîtresse tous les six
mois pour faire la une de voici
je serai au 1 c'est une p écoutez je me
suis mariée très récemment un et 37 ans
et nous me disent que j'ai raconté
pendant les années que le mariage
n'était pas dans vos gènes et finalement
vous avez craqué kit période d'essai
c'est pour des raisons plus
administratif cottereau parce que
l'amour n'a jamais manqué ouais vous
êtes horreur je suis heureux
l'album s'appelle jamais
c'est bien ça aussi
et après de faire ça
montrez une épaule justice
inégaux et
[Musique]
oh
j'accueille maintenant et simon liberati
elie la même chose pour moi
ça
ça va aller
il craint que l'état paul biya
et puis je sais couchepin bâtisse a fait
des plus beaux endroits
simon liberati votre premier roman
anthologie des apparitions chez
flammarion fait beaucoup parler je
dirais même que tout le monde en parle
c'est le cas de le dire voilà alors le
pitch je vais le faire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
je sais
m
c'est fait
alors le pitch était attentes et son
éditeur toi j'ai une telle admiration
pour simon que jeune mike louche je
n'entends pas m'exprimer je peux je peux
pas m'exprimer sans pleurer sur son
livre non mais c'est un très beau livre
bien sûr je suis le pitch d'accord alors
c'est l'histoire de claude et de sa
soeur marina durant la dolce vita des
années 70 le palace le studio 54 saint
tropez ibisa voilà et aujourd'hui quand
le livre commence claude touche le rmi
et marina a disparu voilà c'est le pitch
il passe son temps à se demander où elle
est et il passe son temps à se remémorer
la bonne époque
je crois que je joue car il n'y a rien
d'autre à faire que ça pour le vendre
non
alors ce clown c'est qui c'est un saint
meen et dites-vous à la beauté
luciférienne kimmich tonnes un peu quoi
qui fait partie d'une bande de
pique-assiettes qui traînent autour des
autour des vieilles pies autour des
stars ouais c'est j'avais un ami anglais
qui avait une bonne expression pour ça
c'était webdyn c'est à dire que c'est
pas les has been puisque les has been
tout le monde sait ce qu'est ce que
c'est a priori enfin en tout cas je
pense ici à tout le monde s'y met ou has
been ça veut dire ça existe pas en
anglais en fait il n'a pas été et il se
construit comme s'il avait été quelque
chose
voilà donc laisser quelqu'un méritait sa
vie mais qui n'a pu mentir aux
finalement qu'il trouve ça normal quoi
bein oui bah c'est normal parce qu'à
partir du moment où on vient d'un milieu
un peu un peu moyen puis qu'on n'a rien
fait pour devenir quelque chose on
devient malcorra chose voilà c'est
normal et on vit ça à peu près à peu
près bien grâce aux grasses en effet aux
assedic à ce genre de choses par
ailleurs après il a des souvenirs qui
lui permettent un peu de seins de vivre
jacques au début du bouquin il est mal
quand même effectivement et vit du rmi à
la fin avec un arabe qu'un arabe raciste
ouais ouais mais oui non mais c'est là c
est un garçon enfin ccl mots de berriac
aurais pas rencontrés à visconti quoi
donc c'est assez pathétique quoi mais
bon c'est arrivé à beaucoup de gens et
un allemand étaient assez joli à celle
qu'avait la lumière sur eux comme ça qui
était qui était ravissant mais bon et
ils n'ont pas travaillé ils ont rien
fait du tout et finalement ils ont fini
très mal dans la poubelle et c'est un
peu son cas voilà et marina sa soeur
donc très jeune à l'âge de 12 ans elle
sort avec des talons hauts et des jupes
ras la foudre est vendue par son père
d'amy jetons ou cette expression très
joli c'est un baby tapez 1 ouais le baby
tapin mais ça ça vient de servir de 7,6
du très beau livre qui est moi
christiane f 13 ans droguée prostituée
il y avait deux baby tapin à berlin et
le baby tapin c'est en fait les gens
très jeunes qui qui se vendent parce
qu'en fait quand on quand on quand on a
la grâce on essaie de
de gagner un peu le ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une sorte de complexe d'être
attirés vers les dieux comme ça et ils
sont ils sont attirés vers la vers la
lumière mais bon c'est comme des
papillons de nuit et puis c'est fini
pour l'aca brûle voilà donc c'est
l'histoire de claude de marina et puis
elle est riche et puis à la drogue
et puis à la frime et tout ça fait une
espèce de social grâce à sur la grâce et
sur cette gloire que certaines personnes
on a l'âge de 15-16 ans et qu'elle ne
retrouve jamais c'est une pousse tiens
sauf que c'était des gens qui avaient
pas vraiment le sens des réalités dont
qu'il comprenait pas très bien comment
ça pouvait fonctionner et il y avait il
y avait des tas de gens qui tournait
autour d'eux comme des espèces de comme
les papillons autour de la lampe
finalement ils se sont fait bouffer
alors que la lampe en général elle
bouffe les papillons sont fait bouffer
par les papillons quoi voilà alors on
pense évidemment à ingrid caven de jean
jacques schuhl suite moi toi non mais si
jean veil a commencé très forte
pourquoi vous avez édité ce bouquin
frédéric dans l'argent déjà non
c
éditeur c'est un métier très pénible on
lit beaucoup de choses pas terrible et
et quand j'ai lu le
le texte de liberati je me suis dit ce
métier est une chance ce métier est un
honneur là c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
je sais tout ce que vous avez à dire
mais c'est la révélation de la rentrée
toute la critique et elle a salué il ya
ya ya pas un journaliste qui n'est pas
été inspiré s'avancèrent que des types
qui d'habitude écrivent peut-être pas
des articles passionnants se met à
écrire mieux en ayant lu son livre le
talent et les montages et en ce qui le
concerne
voilà bon moi je dis je sais pas je
trouve que c'est c'est fantastique que
vous l'ayez invités il est très tard non
mais c'est important aussi parce que
c'est bon je louais je pense que
peut-être dans quelques décennies on
continuera de lire son livre et nous
tous on sera oublié vous avez d'autres
quels conseils vous lui donneriez
frédéric à simon liberati de continuer à
vivre ces gens qui savaient pas ce que
s'est passé pas toujours c'est pas
toujours ce qu'il ressort s'effacer très
charmant j'ai eu beaucoup de textes
magnifiques etc
mais j'avais l'impression que c'était un
peu d éloge funèbre et
mais bon c'est vrai que mon livre étant
assez négatif et donnant une image c'est
assez positif de la destruction
on pouvait penser que bon voilà pourquoi
il est pourquoi il est là essayer de
vendre ce bazar qui après tout n'est
qu'un appel à se jeter par la fenêtre
quand même malgré tout quand on le lit
et et bruce et c'est c'est un peu la fin
je crois je crois que c'était là il y
avait une certaine forme de d'esprit
assez à cette époque est constitué à
penser que bon il fallait il fallait y
aller à fond et voilà quoi donc c'est le
livre un peu qui rend hommage à un
certain nombre de gens qui sont plus là
forcément et un certain qu'en disparu à
certains qui sont encore là mais qui
sont plus vraiment vraiment aussi jolie
qu'ils étaient à l'époque et et voilà
c'est une sorte de face et pas un
hommage funèbre mais c'est un hommage à
simon que ce sont les dernières années
folles que qu'on a vécu ouais parce
qu'il ya trois choses qui ont tué à
quand tu es la beauté à ses statuts et
la beauté des automobiles c'est la
sécurité le confort et l'économie en
gros 1 c'est-à-dire un voiture elle
était belle tant qu'elle n'était pas
secure temps qu'elle n'était pas
confortable et tant qu'elle était pas
économique donc on peut voir ça à
travers les automobiles c'est lé symbole
5,80 et voilà c'est ça donc c'est c'est
une forme de lyrisme un peu
un peu à peu nostalgique mais pas voilà
je sais j'ai pas plus grands machins
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
plus là coin alors on se demandait quel
était le livre de la rentrée c'est
celui-là
ces livres de simon libérati j les
apparitions simon liberati s'est invité
chez flammarion
[Musique]
j'ai mon pinceau blind test
ce soir j'accueille dj mehdi
[Musique]
bonsoir
bonsoir dj mehdi nous avait concocté un
blind test avec sunshine et se meurt
dans le titre voilà c'est ça nous avance
pas beaucoup parce que toute façon ça je
veux le nom d interpeller simon la pâte
atteint et connait un pentacle quoi
faire non vous êtes prêt dj mehdi est
comme ça sur une beetle titeuf bien
avant moi george harrison
[Musique]
et alors
c'est le rock je demande à thierry plet
non
comme social beatles enough d'en avant
moi george harrison
c'est un fils et ma fille c'est ma fille
c'est ma fille alors djordje harrison a
composé la chanson gérard bravo mais ça
a été enregistré à l'époque des beatles
voilà avec les honneurs en première
partie
voilà on continue bridji mehdi boney m
ouais
[Musique]
v
et
et petit replay j'avais ces dérives
franck simon le dit d'un quart de poil
bravo prêt d'arriver sur sony c'est une
reprise bobby hebb je crois absolument
tout à fait bravo frédéric dj mehdi
ouais ben un solo
avant
comme ça
[Musique]
ouais donc ça fait deux points pour
l'équipe de gendarmes en est
liberati main
[Applaudissements]
bon j'arrête les jetons l'écouteur non
il y avait des bonnes gratte évidemment
un c'est une autre époque on continue
[Musique]
m
ça fait 3 points pour l'équipe de gérard
darmon bravo gérard
on continue dj mehdi
michel d
[Musique]
jdo
bravo michel z fort ce soit par les
reprises des lovin spoonful toile a
écrit par john sebastian le leader des
lovin spoonful bravo frédéric enregistré
le bronze rachat je sais pas bravo mardi
le dow chemical
oui si l'on connaît le pape aussi je
viens de remarquer que 1,6 quasiment
fait pas c'est jean paul c'est jean
michel qui m'a amené ça de la part de
champagne et oui voilà on continue dj
mehdi
oh ma fille
[Musique]
saleh
à
quel point vos l'équipe de gendarmes en
deux points pour l'équipe de simon
libérer ce qu'on va voir dans des
amphétamines ont besoin d'en faire
[Musique]
attention replay
rennes
[Musique]
mano solo
gérard darmon qui décidément rain sur ce
blog l'ex de leur faire aucun problème
et je pense aux questions
toi qui vas y arriver je suis un peu de
temps oui
ah ouais tu étais confiant toi bien sûr
toi qu'on va arriver à reconstruire
l'équipe
toi aussi il parle de football
on va on croit toujours qu'on va
raccourcir les équipements enfin on dit
qu'on va rencontrer l'équipe on
reconstruit pas l'équipe on a que trois
buts de retard
dj mehdi à toi
le monde
hip hop relutif de gea en larmes en
normes existent elles d'affaires fabien
france il y en a qui seraient les
banques ont suffisamment de réserves
pour les banques ont visité vie à toi
non
mais
sinatra
tergat david à face à 6
je
[Applaudissements]
restera alors aux lycéens
koné
[Applaudissements]
guy ropars 1
[Musique]
sur la douzaine
celle d'armand quel costume 10 carats
bonne et lui tout de suite oui je sais
raison de l'effet simon me dit à
l'oreille il faut savoir perdre parfois
je lui réponds oui c'est maintenant
attention là c'est qu'on fait mais
beigbeder comme tu connais lovin
spoonful je dois connaître le groupe qui
arrive maintenant
dj mehdi total
mais guy
[Musique]
elle
ce qui me place inch et beigbeder c'est
qu' il est très jeune et il connaît des
trucs mais comment tu connais alors que
robert est pathogène et
lambert n'est pas sathonay n'a pu les
lionceaux ont commis les crimes mais
j'ai même joué les kings cependant que
j'étais chez easyjet
bah ouais mais tu peux plus lent à
réagir que j'en ai
[Musique]
les kings à la bafin bombe alors c'est
la fin du par équipes c'est l'équipe
déjà en armant qui gagne haut la main
avec lui point mort gérard ramond
l éthique de simon libérati deux points
alors les bancaires maintenant passe au
bon qu'au super banco méga banco
attention c'est très très compliqué on y
va le bon coup
quand l heure
elle assure en général quand j'ai pas le
tir extra t-rex
[Musique]
car même
m
[Musique]
est-ce que vous donnez tous votre langue
au chat gris thierry mai mais la musique
saxophone et oui on donne notre nouveau
cheval à chaque pays mais la musique
[Musique]
donnes ta langue
alors ça
pensez chakim j'avais pas trouvé chez
lui en bleu
col bateau mais non
john
il était pakistanais ou indienne blanche
à guichen blackhawks guy alors on
continue personne a trouvé le banco le
super banco
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout
bon j'arrête parce que sinon encore la
méga banque où il va retrouver le méga
beaucoup aidé à moyen terme appartient
dans son courrier la méga beaucoup c'est
très bien mais que ça va aller très vite
même si j'allais finir le réseau
victorieux avec ton bon coup avec tombe
super banco parce que le méga banques
aux personnes veulent trouver non bâti
et nous sommes dit oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas évident
cette fois ci
[Musique]
franchement non c'est pas non c'est pas
un mec seraient connus bill withers
bah oui non mais c'est pas un truc
chanoine children were ensemble ferber
s'il te plaît c'est tout alors qu'il
fallait l'ouvrir
c'était tout bon enfant avec lui verser
bravo francine distel son bouquin
s'appelle profession
passage
sion la martinière
j'ai rarement michelle lang
dany boon [ __ ] dure de gabriel aghion
avec jacques dutronc
sortie le 20 octobre plus la bande
originale du film dany boon à l'olympia
du 24 novembre au 2 janvier 2005 vinci
et bravo pour mature et les femmes
frédéric beigbeder jean michel di falco
je crois moi non plus c'était vite et
chez calmann lévy valeria golino là
avec richard anconina venant b dans ce
qui sort le 20 octobre
plus la bande originale du film
mano solo l'album s'appelle les animals
il est en tournée et les dix neuf pages
janvier 2005 à l'olympia merci jacques
vergès la démocratie à visage
hauts-de-seine s'était invité à la table
ronde
herbert léonard
l'album s'appelle entre cham et bleutée
sortie le 18 octobre à cerbère simon
liberati bravo enclos logis des
apparitions
c'est chez flammarion et le blind test
dj mais dans son album si athènes
revisitée voilà dj mehdi
et c'est chez blue 9 mesdames messieurs
voilà c'était tout le monde en bas
rendez vous la semaine prochaine à la
même heure merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
tél
[Applaudissements]
il est le temps
il
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]